[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to our live coverage
of the 2020 protest League
my name is Caleb Denby and I'm joined by
the manager of the world champion st.
Louis Archbishop's hey Mike how do you
feel about the changes going into this
season
oh man well at first I was a little
upset because you know our board for we
recruited all the best board force that
was like our secret weapon that's how we
a QA a two out of the three
championships but uh all right hey you
don't want to write it that's what we'll
get the four best players in the whole
world then okay yeah good luck everybody
of course the big change to the format
this year for the protest League being
that there is no rating limit so all of
that is out the window
and of course st. Louis is a hub for
some of the best chess players in the
world and we we got them all yep yep
Wesley so he was a Webster student so
he's got some st. Louis ties for sure
Fabiano currently resides in uh our dear
city of st. Louis
along with Domingues and we see the
players there's no very good yeah of
course just changing Federation's in the
past year becoming a u.s. player and
making some connections here in st.
Louis joining the winning team yep and
who is our board for board for is none
other than the Liam we another Webster
student and former world rapid and blitz
champion right right yeah I mean you do
not want to play this guy in a fast time
control okay he's just gonna eat you it
really speaks to the power of this team
that we have a world champion playing on
board for bottom and then of course of
course our secret weapon board five four
we can't even play Jeffrey's all fries
on it
yeah another you know of course up and
coming the future of American chess
Jeffrey Zhang crossing the 2700 barrier
in the last year and to not even make
this team is it's crazy and and of
course we ride off the tee with a bunch
of the blue kids maybe we can actually
pull up the full roster here see who
else we've got on the team well going
going forward here we go so check it out
it's over
so slew guys Benjamin Bach sleuth
excellent coach and recruiter Alejandro
Ramirez along with Varco bian who also
works with the slew team yep yep yeah I
just saw him at the Pan Am's in the
picture with him so maybe he helps him
out and trains him up so yeah by the way
our slew did qualify for the final four
yeah congratulations to them they'll be
making their way to the Presidents Cup
once again
to try and bring back home some some
more accolades to see those hopefully
they will and the best I am on the plan
Nicolas Teodoro who I had that
prediction by 2024 it will be played in
the grand chess
Tour event I can guarantee it I look
forward to it he's the best so and
they're right about this team is JJ Ali
mirandy yes taejun's and Georgia who
will be calling the action with you at
come 3:15 and of course our board for
extraordinaires
Josh bloomer Julian Pro LICO and Nicolas
Rosenthal yeah of course Josh and Julian
especially last year bringing home that
that big victory for us right yeah
well Josh got us to the finals without
Josh's help we ended up tying my
Clarisonic Ferrero's 8 8 yeah but and we
advanced on draw odds and earlier in
that match Josh was able to draw nicolas
checque up yeah really giving us the the
key half points or full points even when
we really needed them to round out the
right so so yeah we are in debt to judge
me and by the way believe it out with
all these guys on the roster
Josh bloomer will be playing in one of
our seven matches all right I guarantee
it I will see how he manages to perform
brave new approach s League where
everybody's at 2700 right yeah yeah yeah
so right right our matchup today is
against the New York Marshalls and they
have everybody on their team is above
the 2600 barrier so yeah of course I
think we can actually pull up and see
who exactly we're playing they do have
one very very notable name
are you Nakamura a former st. Louis
Archbishop of the u.s. chesley not
approach s where's the precursor to the
protest League I think the the
Commissioner Greg Shehadeh was really
championing the u.s. chess league back
in the day on ICC right way back in
prehistoric era oh yeah of course the
Cara Nakamura the New York Marshal's
board one will be the guy to look out
for of course Macario has always been
one of the top online players if not be
top online player and a very very strong
player in both blitz and rapid as well
as you know a mainstay in the top ten
oh sure and yeah and this year and
another change for the protest League
instead of the g15 plus two second
increment it is now G ten plus two
second increment which would bode well
for a key core oh for sure yeah he if he
figures out that this game has actually
begun instead of just like ripping off
in his face okay so if he gets that
right maybe he's got a chance all right
what else we go we've got a youngster on
the team as well in San seven so he'll
be somebody to look out for of course
one of the top u.s. juniors not too far
behind Geoffrey Zhang actually yeah and
I say junior I think he's he's actually
over 19 now Susan even qualified so way
back in the day I was actually the one
to arbitrate his Grandmaster clinching
victory against Gore Yvette's right here
in the st. Louis chess club yes so Sam a
turncoat turning against us now playing
for the nation but also this sign table
is a very very talented player
definitely he's one to look out for he
might be able to score one or two upsets
and then rounding out the team is of
course Miranda and a player I don't know
too much about but over 2600 I'm sure
he's you gotta be ok I gotta be ok so I
agree also in this event what am I
trying to say here what am I trying to
say I'm so exciting today we're the
defending champions we were actually
double champions last year believe it or
not maybe
people then know about this there was a
thing called the summer series and we
wanted we want it again all right with
the help of Josh bloom and especially
vara Cobian was was that our GM
representative for that summer series
yes yes he he led the players in the
matches the online players like like I
got the Aixa to play for the
Archbishop's last year scoring and so
did Caleb yeah we all we all got a part
of it yeah there's a lot of fun yeah so
yeah we won the regular season we won
the summer Series in 2019 we're hoping
to repeat here in 2020 and in this first
matchup while we did just take a look at
some of the the New York Marshalls and
of course there are very very great
players but it turns out even Hikaru
Nakamura is unfavored and how many all
right yeah exactly what I was getting
here so they are going to need some
upsets a lot of upsets because guess
what of the 16 games today the
Archbishop's are favored in 15 of them
15 so even he clora their board one is
gonna be gunning for some upsets he's
only favored against Liam Lee yeah of
course you know Bobby on board one
wesley on board too
it's gonna be a crazy crazy event
tonight you made my job a lot easier
protests Lee thanks a lot thank you
thank you yeah of course without this
rating cap this is this is really gonna
give us I think a huge edge in the
tournament what what teams are you
looking out for though okay so we have
our arch rivals coming up on week three
the Chicago wind so the Chicago wind is
basically three teams into one so they
try to form like a super team of course
Webster Chicago and Minnesota all formed
one team the Chicago wind so any big
names on that team that we're gonna have
to look out for
I would think they've got like Italy a
nice Nick a brain Elliott horse yeah
he's a he's a heck of a player and I
think they have Andrew a tang ah
Andrew tanks
yeah and your tank just I shout out to
another he might be on the Chicago one
as well Aaron Verbinski just got his uh
finally got his I untitled yeah shout
out the education student with his win
against it sounds like we've got a lot
of the slew team Chicago seems like
they've got a lot of the Webster teams
so believe it or not even a st. Louis
rivalry going on there yeah we've got so
many strong players we had to give some
of them away to Chicago so so yeah an
interesting part about another rule
change in the protesting this year is in
order to be considered local you
actually is that by where you live it's
by whatever your Federation is so
actually like Benjamin Bach and Nikolas
Theodore are considered free agents this
year for us since their Federation is
from a different yeah of course those
two players ascending Saint attending
st. Louis University but representing
their home countries while they play so
they're free agents that we picked up
this year right you can only play two
free agents and two local at a time or
the four players so you can't just thank
your team with a free age understood so
we talked a lot about how strong our
team is and how we're squaring up
against the the other teams this year
but what is the actual format like of
course there's the regular season and
then the player
there's just seven games this season so
it's very compact all right so it's a so
four players per team all play ball so
if your board one you're going to be
playing board four three two and one and
likewise okay so if you get eight and a
half out of 16 you'll get an act and
additional ten points added to your to
your score so basically you really want
to get eight and a half points but for
every additional point you get like if
we get 15 points they'll add ten so
we'll have 25 points in the stand so if
we win every game we're favored in we
can beat will be it will be top at 25 so
what you're saying is you know even if
we have won the match there's still a
lot to play alright guys you got to
improve your standing in the division
right right now and so the four highest
Turner's at the end of the season we'll
all get an automatic full point buy-in
past the plastic very valuable right 13
teams will make the playoffs this year
and forget the first round bye and then
we and then you know you're in the
quarterfinals and then if you win that
you'll be in that Final Four all right
so once again very important the points
are not just decided by who wins the
match it's what your score is in the
match so if you if you have blowouts
every round you you're really improving
your chance right
you'll never be you'll never speak will
never be seven and Oh we'll just have
enough points that that reflects that we
want all our matches mm-hmm so you
mentioned Chicago being a rival are they
actually in our division this season yes
yes so so there's three divisions now we
are in the Western Division and you can
check this all out at protest League
calm but yeah we were in our division
with UK lions all the Canada just for us
yeah Chris Chuck I think they were
actually playing earlier today in their
match yeah yeah so we're are the
featured match today at 3:15 so all the
other Western Division games should be
concluded by now or just just about
wrapping up like the Chicago when were
in the action as well so and by the way
if you do go to the protest League comp
standings like check this out they have
the Archbishop's and dead laughs can you
believe that that's the only time we're
gonna be there we're gonna flip the
script on that and expect to see us at
the top of the leader okay so yeah of
course the Chicago when we mentioned
inner in our section of course the
Canada chest bra is an online favorite
but in the ends there's nobody that can
compete with this team that we've got
lined up right Mike I mean they just
made it too easy this year I mean that
they try to foil us they tried to foil
us with our board forward straight
everybody was complaining and how do
they get the best more force well I'll
give you a hint they got a really good
general manager this yeah once again we
see that full roster there with Bobby
Lenny
Wesley and Liam Lee all in our top floor
all over 2700 and Bobby of course way
over 2,800 these days look at that
roster all fairness to us
besides Josh bloomer and Jeffrey Jean
they all have strong strong st. Louis
connections most of them actually reside
here so it's not like we're picking
these guys up from you know yeah you say
Jeffrey Zhang doesn't have strong st.
Louis connections he doesn't live here
but it feels like he's he just won the
Fall Classic he's now a three-time
classic Series champion winning the
summer chess classic twice and now that
the fall chess class may be spring and
he did quit his clinching Grandmaster
title at the Chess Club right after the
2015 US Junior Open yes so a great
pickup in Jeffrey Zhang this year as
well and this this round to start off
we're of course fielding our top four so
that would be only a true test of the
the New York Marshalls to see how they
they can they can stand up against yeah
the battering of 427 all right Mike so I
think we've got a lot to look forward to
today I see online here we've got
actually Lenny a I think was warming up
with some Bullock games fans all our
players are starting to log on here is
Fabiano log on to the stockholm slash
life yeah let's see let's see there it
is
he led us to victory last year in San
Francisco the one and only Fabiano
Carolina and guess what if it was a
Google News Alert story it was called
the top seven uh chess moments in 2019
yeah number seven that's that's right
where you want to be to at the top of
the page st. Louis Archbishop's clinched
the champion the 2019 Protoss League
World Championship world champion I got
the proof right here don't World
Championship he went of course seven and
a half out of eight so yeah if I could
play devil's advocate of course Fabiano
one of the best classical chess players
of all time
drew Magnus
in the World Championship going a level
score after the classical but there's
always been some talk some doubters
thinking maybe he's not the greatest
rapid player not the greatest blitz
player so how do you think about Bobby
and in the board one slot facing people
like a cargo facing people like Hikaru
so right if one guy on this whole planet
didn't exist who would get all the
accolades right just is Magnus in the
protest League no so we got the best guy
all right so you think Bobby is the
number one seed even though but the time
controls so fast I mean I feel bad for
the guy that he has haters it's like
okay okay this one guy is better than me
okay forget that guy he's not in this
league so I'm the best and and he's
gonna end any he was the MVP last year
two of the finals and the regular season
so okay well we're favored and 15 of the
16 matchups today like you said what's
your predicted score what do you think
we're gonna get you think we'll get the
full 15 the full 16 well one could hope
what but as I tell my players hey just
give me eight and a half and then we'll
get the extra bonus ten and we'll take
it from there
just win the match all right well Mike
is there anything else you wanna say
about the the protest League and our
chances in it this year before we go to
a break I really like my chances but you
know just let's get to the Final Four
and take it from there and see what
happens
all right thanks very much to world
champion manager Mike comer we will be
taking a short break and we will come
back at 3:15 with me and dorsa Derrick
Shani with live coverage over the
protest against the st. Louis you'll
probably want to watch the Cardinals or
the Blues what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major air boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway or stir bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Loup is always
exploring be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind
art experience we get your autograph
yeah of course I think it's pretty cool
that you love chess so much we love
chess - I just program and gotta meet a
real-life Grandmaster I got to be this
big one time I put a police captain
after school and check wait a min 27
moves wow I should be asking for your
autographs
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a trap here for those of you
who are new to chess it might look like
no one but it still is something we call
hustle be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience we get your
autograph of course I think it's pretty
cool that you love chess so much we love
chess to enjoy school chess program and
gotta meet a real-life Grandmaster I
have this big one time I put a police
captain after school and check my name
in 27 moves Wow
I should be asking for your autographs
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. chess
championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the World Chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st. Louis chess campus visit STL chess
campus org
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our live
coverage of round one of the 2020
protests leak my name is caleb ben b and
i'm joined by the wonderful
international master dorsa derek Shani
ya dorsa how do you feel about the st.
Louis Archbishop's this year perhaps
proud yeah of course you're a member of
the team are you looking to get in on
some of the action later on of course
so today of course as we we saw with
with Mike comer we are squaring off
against the New York Marshalls of course
that's a very tough team who are you
looking out for on the Marshalls I'm not
gonna save now but as soon as the games
of starts weekend starts seeing which
Jews should look more into yeah of
course you never know which games are
gonna be interesting
why don't we take a look actually at our
round one pairings against the Marshalls
of course Liam Leigh is against board
one for the New York Marshalls Hikaru
Nakamura and this is actually the only
game where the Marshalls are favored so
we'll have to keep an eye on this one
here see if Liam we can pull up the only
possible upset for us Wesley so was
playing you saying off San seven against
money a Dominguez and Miranda against
Bobby that's Miranda of course board for
the Marshalls against board one for Fabi
and then in the coming rounds everybody
will will have a chance to play
everybody else it's it's kind of a
round-robin system well just looking at
a pairings I don't know I I don't know
how much to be concerned or give any
concern is the right words before he
cards game cuz oh hey Cole let's wrap it
that's yeah he's he's really he's
awesome in those yeah he's a Titan of
especially online blitz and refugees
he's of course always setting these
rating records and being the top-rated
account on chess calm for it for some
time it'll be one to look out for
honestly right now I'm thinking maybe
the Dominguez Savion match would be the
one that's we would be spending the most
yes same 70 of course a younger player I
actually haven't seen him compete and
too many of these online tournaments I
don't know if you remember any of his
games but no no no actually I don't
it's am a bit of a wild card then it's
I'm not sure how well he'll he'll
compete in this this game in 10+2 format
of course an even faster time control
thing than last year
of course we're just waiting for these
games to get underway if you're in the
twitch chat be sure to say hello I do
have that pulled up here if you have any
questions for us we'd be happy to answer
but in the meantime I'm kind of
wondering why did they change the time
control I don't know just to make it
more exciting I guess you know game in
15 it's just it's too slow in this
modern age of chess we need game in 10
get get these games going get into that
time pressure even even more quickly
yeah before we start one thing that I've
been I read about and it was really
interesting for me was so I'm sure we
all know about the thing that happened
between Magnus and here's the world
world blitz and rapid it was so for
those of you just to do a tiny recap
fear was Jonah had more pawns and it
technically was a winning women's game
okay but he ran out of the time since
Magnus didn't have any pawns
theoretically from what I understood in
online playing stats you draw
but in a real chess technically there
could be a position where feriss job
would like help make himself something
like this is one of those weird rule
changes between fidei and even the USDF
doesn't the other way in the USCF you
need mating material which is you know I
think like a bishop and a knight
qualifies a pawn qualifies because you
can make a queen
whereas in feed a if checkmate is legal
if you can legally achieve a checkmate
then it counts as a win for the player
who did not it was yeah it's something
got me really thinking it's those little
things are really yeah and it can be
very confusing even for some of these
top players of course there's there's
feels like there's a controversy every
year that it was with the game either
than a draw and I thought he was fine
with it but then the arbiter had to
follow the rules and well see their
rules
yeah of course an unfortunate turn of
events for furries really interesting
I'm sure I'll have plenty of more
chances to take down Magnus in in the
coming years as he's just getting
started in his I'm sure going what's
going to be a historic chess career
interesting uh well we are still waiting
for these games to get started here
let's see I think freesia is actually
playing right now against Daniel
Meredith's key in the protest League the
freesia of course on the Montreal or the
Canada chess pros now no longer mono so
he is actually playing against us in our
division so I have to be on the lookout
for yeah I don't actually remember last
year I think he was playing for sure we
were doing one of the ones yeah her
series was we were doing it against him
mm-hmm yeah but of course so for you a
young talent now is playing in the
process League for the month for the
Canada chess brows once again as they
are in our division we will be facing
off against him who do you think's a
bigger threat was Takara Nakamura or
freesia of course Perugia is another one
of those guys who's who actually
actually grew up playing online and he's
of course setting those those trading
records as well getting insane insane
levels of chess I'm still gonna go with
takara for now if you asked me that
question
next year yeah
answer understandably I think yeah those
those two players actually faced off
against each other and one of the speech
has Championships and that that one did
end up going to Cara's way yeah I'm sure
there were yeah no I just I remember
some some energy that that Perugia game
where he himself admitted yeah car was
still still better than me but check
back in in a little bit we'll see of
course it's tough to keep that that guy
down there are very few people in the
world that I would pick in a speed match
against Alireza of Ruza right now in a
car what do you want them but yeah okay
well once again just waiting on these
games to get started
of course yeah I don't know what do you
want what do you want to talk about yeah
here we have the matchups once again
Liam Lee against Corona camara wisely so
against me saying of sam-7
against Dominguez and Miranda against
Fabiano Cara wanna I remember I was
playing a tournament I think was like
Asian Championships in 2014 I want to
say and the Liam Lee was there and I
think if that was about the time that
she was considering transferring to play
for Webster Oh interesting
yeah I thought that was very interesting
and if I'm not mistaken I also played
against his wife but before I think he
was in 13th
who is that again um thank his wife yeah
no nobody knows okay I know I mean it's
not a secret
yeah I remember the game of course the
classic chest so yeah Liam Lee of course
was considering coming to Webster and to
Vegas is a player who has now
transferred federations from Cuba over
to the United States he was incensed
doesn't he yeah I believe so he does I
think he you know these chess players
don't really live anywhere they're
always traveling but I think he
a place here in st. Louis so I'm not
sure where his official residence he
actually is but yeah it looks like chess
comm is is setting up for further intro
here introducing our players as we've
already done once again we have four
players of where some of the best
players in in all of chess especially
grandpa chess as well
Liam Lee on our board for as we were
mentioning is actually a world champion
in fast time control chess so it's tough
to believe that he could be our bottom
board but here he is nonetheless well I
think this well maybe I thought I
wouldn't be worried about this match
against Hikaru but yeah you think Cara's
gonna take him down
alright maybe that'll make things
somewhat interesting if if the marshals
do manage to score some points well I'm
feeling very very confident in the same
those archbishops chances here yeah I
think I also well back you back when I
was still in Iran and I was playing the
tournament's nearby I think um the yeah
there go sign up quite tournaments in
Iran and I think I was considering
getting him as a coach it never went
true but yes I know a name that I've
always heard but I'm not actually super
familiar with with his results I mean
when they had for example from the Arab
Spring it's difficult it's difficult to
follow up those names so 2020 is looking
to be an interesting year for chess of
course that the candidates are coming up
as well and that's very relevant for at
least one of our players on our team
Fabiano Cara wanna of course the 2018
World Championship Challenger he's
automatically in the candidates and
coming up in March that'll be a very
interesting tournament to watch I would
feel about his chances specifically he's
gonna win it
I'm on board I'm on board with that
Bobby you know of course solidly the
number two chess player in the world for
quite some time
thing is in chess you really need the
good support group and he hasn't yeah
here in the st. Louis I think he's
really found a good a group of people to
help support him in his chest career and
he'll continue on to bigger and better
things and hopefully by the end of this
year there will be a new world champion
yeah so like we said there are seven
rounds on the regular season
today is round one against the New York
marshals and once again it's not whether
or not you win the match but it's how
many points you score so we're not going
to slow down once we inevitably do get
to eight and a half points no 216 will
be going for as many points as possible
to really give us that edge in the
coming match ups as well
we aren't Kosan but what are this
scheduled to start so they were supposed
to start at 3:15 we are too kind of
treading water here and of course I said
first round of the match it's actually
the whole match is played today it's the
first round or the first match of the
season rather there are seven matches in
the season and today we are doing our
entire match against the New York
marshals which is 16 games long yeah
and looking at the chess calm stream it
looks like they are just about ready to
get going here
I think so too maybe 30 30 more seconds
nobody knows anyways it looks as though
ferocious game has actually ended again
started skiing uh-huh and I think that
concludes the match of the chest bras
against let's see what team is this here
the California unicorns interesting
interesting team name there so the chest
bras is more favorite from the start
Wendy I think so I'm not sure actually
how that game how that match ended up
but I think they did well if I'm not
mistaken
yeah I'm not sure what the final score
in that match was but it doesn't matter
we're gonna beat their score against the
New York Marshalls quite quite certain
of it
so tell me a little bit about the
recruiting process with Mike Humber
being being the manager for the
archbishop's what was that like did he
approach you with the opportunity did
you approach him was last year well I do
remember that I was asking about it
right and that's I was asking how is it
because I wasn't really familiar with
the the recording process and I wasn't
even sure if I would get the chance to
play because of their racing games yeah
no it's it's it's a crazy crazy season
some friends of mine the chest bub blast
actually Susan 18 yeah
20:18 fall and at that point in front of
my friends Mike was like yeah yeah want
to be on the team okay here's the
contract it was awesome because my
friends are like wow you get to play
chess for like an evening and you have
fun and you come here and you get so
much money
yes it's a wonderful opportunity yeah of
course Mike comes off a little bit
intense but he really gets the job done
as a manager recruiting some of the best
chess players in the entire world
to play for the st. Louis Archbishop's
you guys without further ado it looks
like our first game has started here of
course it is Lee Anne Lee against a car
of Nakamura so what are you pulled the
board started we have d4 yes so Liam
going with one d4 a carro has made his
first move in d5 and then Queens gambit
oh except it so you [ __ ] family Emily
this that's opening a little bit more
ambitious than within the standard
Knight f3 III stay yeah this is no
interesting um well um I don't play this
opening is wise but game aboard ah all
right
like this looks like chestnut comes
having some some difficulties here I
mean we're gonna get a little little bit
of a redo on that one maybe and we'll
see a repeat of the opening oh the time
control is in clearance uh of course the
new time control is named in ten minutes
not gaming 15 and it looks as though we
are underway I once again will see if
they repeat it looks as though they're
they're planning to yeah yeah so we
haven't shaved that position and liam
chooses Knight f3 and so this is an
interesting imbalance in the opening
here black takes some time to move this
night from d5 to b6 and white develops a
pretty big center this looks a lot like
the opening for Knight f6 e 595 before
yeah a little bit uh-oh and we have nine
fish of f7 and this is a line that I'm
not familiar with but it looks as though
blankets this d4 pawn and it charges the
f7 pawn
yeah I'm that's right familiar with this
line as as white but as black I'm not
sure if that's would be my choice to
play yeah of course you give up the
castling rights uh-huh and while you do
get to kind of take over the white
center you know you're kind of lacking
targets once that centers go yeah
exactly
so as white I would expect just simple
development getting castled and then
maybe the black king will find himself
without a safe home yeah well this is
definitely one of the interesting game
that's we should keep looking explore
but let's take a second yeah all the
other games yeah have also gotten
underway
I'm gonna check father's game for a
second yeah it looks like Bobby is
playing
a very standard setup against against
1.d4 yeah so when you said standards so
96 is a little bit strange yeah yeah I
did not notice that quite at first this
is really interesting I mean I've played
the names 1996 but I you know get really
played Bishop before and also the 9th is
on c3 but this is really interesting
yes so with this knight on c6 correct me
if I'm wrong usually the idea is to go
for a little bit of an earlier e5 push
that's the advantage that's what I'm
talk - yeah but in here trying to push a
5 and your Bishop is kind of a nice
place that it's before I want to say
what the bishop will be moving without
further delay I know that a3 is then
that is true that's been SAT so maybe
we'll see Bishop d6 with the idea of Eve
I know we actually see a trade yeah I
guess another advantage to having this
knight on c6 is that you're kind of
preventing this night from f3 moving -
yeah also the thing is like in this in
this situations mm-hmm
black is treading something with every
move whereas why it's not nothing that's
right now the that the thing to look at
this black is whether or not C or E 7
Bishop is going to actually get out or
pee behind it yes it's a little bit
hemmed in but it does serve a bit of a
useful purpose right it helps control
this efore square which is very relevant
to keeping this night on such a strong
outpost yeah a pay for coming not
letting white played before yes this was
this was excellent move you might even
want to try to play it for yourself and
then put to your Knight to a5 and B the
b3 post yeah bring this night into b3
still keeps the pressure up on on d4
yeah and as well as you know I control
some he squares in the white
and why don't we take a quick look yes
that's some of these organs though I
think Lydia Dominguez is playing a very
interesting Sicilian defense and so
we'll see what's uh what's going on in
this game
Wow yes so this game is definitely one
to look out that really some people have
it looks as though we have of course
neither yeah the night worth and of
course the long Castille theory um yes
so there's this this h5 move that is
sometimes played in these opening lines
right and I'm familiar with g3 though g3
is a little bit strange I'm not quite
sure what the idea is to be honest with
you but as black what are you looking to
play here do you look to Castle kingside
or do you want to keep your King in the
center
I think sons are pronounced well you're
not gonna do with Kings side because
that gives us why it's a clear path of
attack
well Queen set is also out of the
question because you would want your
rook to be on c8 or b8 and you want to
start pushing b5 maybe you'll get some
nice sacrifices replace the knight c3
hmm those are some things to look for
yeah so my impression in this position
is blacks plane is is pretty clear right
you want to expand on the Queen side
with b5 as you're saying bring the rooks
into the game but as white I'm not
entirely sure what what the plan is you
can probably start going for f4 maybe
that's why you played g 3n g 3 of course
defending the f4 squared but you know
what what's what's the idea with with f4
even though they're not quite sure I
understand well I mean you kind of have
to try and open up the center because if
not why it's just a dinged-up
yeah no no with the way that uh that
white is played f4 is giving up this key
E for square and you might see this
knife from f6 come into the game or you
might see the punch from a 5 move to e4
keeping the center of the ball closed
the thing is um the way that the pieces
were exchanged
so usually the night of its it's a good
idea to try and keep this Bishop on e7
trapped but at the same time I mean
ideally you would want to exchange off
you would want to have a night here in
the outpost right but the nights are 85
I'm not entirely sure what's it doing
yeah c6 but you do see some lines right
where white gets this pawn on d5 ready
tonight and it's used to kind of cramp
the black position but I think usually
that's combined more with some some more
expansion on the Queen side actually
rather than the castling on the Queen
side and it looks to me like d5 is
actually just a very big weakness
there's rook c5 even threatened you
exactly there's no just pick up upon on
this white does something you know I'm a
huge fan of funniest position here
actually
me too so there's I think it's a very
safe position and I think it's very
clear path especially yeah I mean how do
you stop rook c5 for the night just came
from b3 yeah and unless you're maybe
Bishop g2 followed by f4 but it looks
kind of artificial to defend oh yeah I
don't think that's that's the right
thick to go maybe Rock c5 you can I mean
you don't want to push c4 yeah you might
have to but you don't want to oh I was
thinking maybe something like maybe
knight c6 and then you you pick up the
the bishop on e7 try but then droopy
500k knight c6
yeah okay rook c5 so do you mean like
knight c6 here yeah that's what I was
thinking because if you play 96 there's
no c5 but then there's 95 yeah 95 oh
then you could think about 97 97 I want
to say Queen d6 but yeah trading off
some of the pawns interesting see maybe
knight c6 was the idea and now he's just
deciding whether or not he can actually
get away with it
I think it's it feels slightly strange
but maybe it's the other thing to know I
don't think that's gonna work I was
considering if somehow the bishop likes
white bishop was on e4
that's would be that would be a nice
improvement because if the bishop is on
e for your kind of like walking
everything here yeah it's difficult to
achieve and then you could go for 96 but
yeah it is the feel of um why don't uh
well it looks like Sam's gonna be
thinking on this movie yeah for a while
let me go back to the car again because
it looks as though the point of Pleiss
opening well oh you can yeah very
quickly cuz I just saw the time
difference I was like well yeah all
right let's do this super quickly oh
yeah you know there's mostly shows game
against the sign of and it looks like a
Kings Indian defense
[Music]
I'm ROTC back like never pronounce 7 it
neither can i nobody nobody knows oh
yeah I like I like playing it though I
love this isn't his wife yeah this is
this isn't one opening that I've I've
just never been good at from from either
side but you have so much space with
life and your plan is so clear and yes
somehow it just never works that to me
but we see that how White has already
connected the rooks and the black pieces
it's a little unclear what they're doing
right you want to play for b5 gonna play
for d5 but you can't really achieve
either Knight b6 is already a threat
this night for white might actually come
to d5 in the future and it's a little
uncomfortable there could be some g5 g
4m g 4g fans for once
yeah well over at four of fun and so
here's the changing structure for black
yeah it was interesting yeah generally
in this type of structure you see the
light squared bishop for light being
kind of the bad piece right it's stuck
behind the pawns on e4 and c4 but here I
think Wesley thinks you know there's an
open diagonal for it if you can get to
f3 then it's gonna be a very powerful
Bishop pressuring the Queen
that is true a lot here is where blacks
don't think like spend the minutes and
write some here another minutes and half
here another minute and a half here
habitually show they said it's such a
cool effect to get again Wow oh and we
have to for I was gonna mention this
view 96 I thought this should be six
just to block it off but well it makes
more sense to keep the bishop I guess
again and what do you play here for glad
you you have to capture I guess I think
so you do cuz if you don't do your rooks
oh I will fork take trouble and of
course the for ak7 there's night CA yes
picking up that which are then 97's
coming to do so tech sticks this Bishop
gets to the diagonal before the light
square bishop
okay well the thing is if this pawn on a
to was on a five I think that that would
be a big help for for whites position
yeah I agree
and I do think another reason Wesley
chose to keep this light square bishop
is is now b5 is difficult to achieve
it's it's keeping pressure up on that be
v square and this like can't break in
the center with b5 somehow he's he's
going to be a little bit cramped
although some of the bishops have found
some activity for him I'm thinking how
would we try to kick off the the e4
Bishop yeah I think I was gonna mention
just King III that's what I thought but
could there be like d5 yeah I'm trying
to open that up but then the e7 pawn is
the way to week yeah it's interesting
yeah I like what's these chances here
all the time as well yeah the the black
bishops have done some activity
so there is some some reason to be
cautious yes I did want to mention
though this a Cara game looks like a car
the point of his opening was was he gets
to win upon but in exchange for that his
king is weak and actually his Bishop on
a date thanks
we saw this exchange yeah we saw this
and then black is picking up the e5 pawn
and this is his reasoning - for allowing
white to castle and and preventing the
castling rights for black as he gets
this extra pawn Wow hmm I can see why
this would be appealing for blocks of
play on this week but here um there's
been Weitzman almost three minutes
singing bowl so now he knows definitely
not prep order idath brooks already Wow
Bishop f4 is a very nice move of course
in openings like this where you've given
up upon you really need to get activated
at all costs so you need to play moves
like Bishop f4 you need to play moves
like you know leaving the knight on c5
hanging because if you allow black to
consolidate and get develops then you're
gonna simply be worse yes exactly
um it's interesting the Bishop f4 move
the Queen has to go back
Queeny for I think it's kind of force
rights because if not 24 then your
Bishop is gonna hang it you're nice kind
of hanging loops yeah and I mean you
don't want to play a Bishop b5 trading
on ya powerful Bishop it's the queen e4
gets the Queen's off the board which is
good news for in Cairo but after some
more moves we see Bishop c7 rook c8
Bishop comes back nature can be 295
attacks of course the Karim it needs to
maintain this material edge otherwise he
will simply be worse so taking on be
delicious is pretty force not seen a
light of day yet and a6 trying to keep
the pawn and we do see this check now
king of a success picks up d5 trying to
bring out the bishop so white has taken
the time to regain his pawn now but in
return the knight on a 6 is a little bit
out of play and it's a little unclear
actually to me huh how liam lee intends
to get this knight into the game well a
tree kind of makes sense because worst
kissin are you would just want to play
Knight before and I've changed it off
there I think a3 was actually forced
otherwise okay it would be kind of
trapping the night
yeah so 8-3 trying to argue with and
then Bishop c5 is it it's not a move I
would have expected to see well I think
that the point is if you take it to the
a Knights even though you would get rid
of those nights there's like a clear
path for this palm to become well baby
queen yeah maybe we could try to block
hate on the scene three square actually
I'm not entirely sure how you would do
that because let's say if Knight takes
d5 yeah whoa whoa whoa you do have a
mouse here yes
so night before was was played instead
we see but yeah but here if you try and
take it at this night which I can't if
she tries to take it they take back with
a pawn and bright you you can't place a
rook on c1 and you can't try to block it
off that easily you might want to you
could probably try and do something like
f4 and then maybe should be won but it's
your pieces would be way out of
coordination so before instead yeah king
g6 take the knight take the Knights
and I like what we emily has has done
here he's just playing fairly simply
he's getting his rep cinnaminson kind of
worrying for me yeah only two minutes
left but of course he's a very
experienced blitz player as well and I
don't think white really has has any
problems here you can expect maybe
eventually an f3 move just to simply
cement this night on the e4 square give
the bishop some options to retreat and I
think this one is going to fizzle out
into a draw I think so too
just have to be careful not to give too
many opportunities so negative 2 is kind
of an uncomfortable move for white you
don't really want to take on d8 and give
up this this d-file but it seems there's
no other option that is true because if
you keep both troops on the games then
black already has a rope on the gate
maybe if it tried to exchange it off and
played something like 82 to keep to keep
the pieces wok that as possible but yeah
I think I actually like that plan quite
a bit the e2 is a very nice square for
the King the only thing to look out for
is if the Black Knights somehow made its
way to the d4 square but that looks like
it's always ways off in the future
yeah I'm not officially that's realistic
yeah so I like e to quite a bit for the
King I thinking e Tuesday I was also
considering this plane with a four of
course taking on c5 because black a
powerful pass C pawn but if I can make
use of the a pawn then if eighth for
Brooklyn 24 but then a 54 you always
have 95 take and then you can start
pushing 85 as well I think this yeah
this was a good idea so we see Bishop d4
from the car taking away this option of
capturing on c5 you got him with the
room I think oh you know this is a very
nice maneuver so the White Knight is
actually following this Bishop the the
blacks King activity is kind of worrying
me honestly
yeah and now you don't really want to
take this bishop once again it's gonna
be a powerful pun and I think Hikaru is
simply winning upon here you know Knight
takes a four yeah just just it's a clean
pun this one seems to be going going the
wrong direction
yeah well I mean there's a still good
fight left
but yeah rook b5 just doesn't King
seafood doesn't it doesn't feel too
active blacks King his way to thank you
I think this one might go car is way of
course this is the only game in this
entire match we're New York Marshalls
are favored so it's no big no big loss
to us but it I I'm fully aquatic so yes
technically it's it's not yeah I was
gonna say that that's easy but yeah you
do have some problems with with this
epon you don't really want to play
before just yet I think it could get
slightly awkward to try to defend that
pawn but this b-pawn is is passed and it
is not going to fall off the board
anytime soon
oh yeah Knight c3 is it's very very nice
and you're just going yeah it just
simply defends the pond okay let's let's
get off of this game it looks like
Leslie so has a four and a half minute
advantage this opponent down for 17
seconds see how is a position upon up
this should be easy better looks better
activity
it looks like Wesley's going after the a
f5 pond with this move actually here we
see a check here the Kings u45 probably
coming up oh oh and a floor this move
isn't it's me getting the job done right
what can you just take it yeah just take
and then after rook a three you can't
even play Yorick a six yeah and your
your pawn yeah and then you can even
expect to see so Rick a6 Rick a7 I think
is a very big threat or maybe you're
okay six just a five and a six and you
pick up try and pick up the b5 they be
for pawn that as well but yeah so we see
Rick t7 because Rick a7 I think would
have just been true maybe a maybe even
yeah yeah I like a five but I don't I
folks nice so okay so I think what's
gonna defend his deep on with this king
and then he's going to simply use the
the d2 rook it's an attack the before
upon and that'll be that'll be good
enough I think
okay so I ever I'll just look yeah just
to avoid roasty fives I like it I like
it
oh well maybe I was thinking maybe a BCC
Kruk c5 then Ruby five but there is this
easy quick I think yeah and so this
looks dead boss to me yeah and also
gather your has only five seconds three
three two one oh the game could end here
no Rick rook d7 just in time sorry let's
pop over to the other notes we haven't
read over result yeah hikaru did end up
converting that game as we expected some
very nice nice play from him you know
changing that that slight advantage and
King activity into material and then
eventually of course just just
converting I've heard the king is
supposed to be active in him game well
yeah how is the tough customer I think
though Dominguez position looks very
very promising and ii see what's going
on I think he's winning he was
obliterated the White King side and the
White King is actually under quite a
massive attack as well as the wife issue
is simply hanging we do is coming yeah
there's a threat of checkmate actually
you don't have time to play move like
Queen f6 with white because simply Queen
see tree check King a 1 and then Queen
and you can be sufficient because if one
brook is kind of well also other
checkmate Queen takes f1 rook c1 a much
much better much better checkmate so
what are you wearing supposed to do
Queen well what can you do
I think resign is this seems best option
here to be real or not real for like
your cup floor is still just checkmate -
Quincy - yeah I think Bishop so we're
expecting Wesley and Lenny a to win
pretty comfortably and it looks like
Bobby has found himself in an exchange
down endgame but with good winning
chances I think Bobby's planning g5
followed by h4 yes the past H pawn is
gonna be very very powerful yes I'm a
little worried about the eighth floor
pawn if it could be picked up could
probably be dangerous I don't think
there's there's too much danger of that
this trick really can't leave the third
rank or else rook p3 I think it's gonna
be a powerful option for for black and
then Rick f3 and it takes g3 and then
the three pawns on the Kings side should
be able to get the job done
yeah and the relevant factor in these
end games where one side has pawns on
the Kings side and the other s pawns on
the Queen side it's not so much the
number of funds that's important but
it's how far up the board they are and
Fabi has a massive lead in so yeah we do
simply see you h4 and Bobby makes this
passed upon I mean White has to block
the chance of h2 because of h3 is coming
it's [ __ ] block H - yes of course your
experience belong behind pestilence
so rook c8 preparing that but Bobby gets
there first and now I don't I don't see
oh we have two other results - student
so those two games did go the way we
expected yeah Wesley did convert this
end game against we sign off and Lonnie
a did manage to defeat
I mean in the case as well so so far the
score is two to one in our favor
hikaru getting the job done for the
marshals but the other three boards seem
to be leaning in our direction quite
heavily um well honestly if bobby draws
this - I think it should be good enough
but I don't know this should be this
simpler should be winning rook c6 is a
very nasty move all right
the white king wants to blockade the
pawn from age two but there's actually
checkmating ideas this Rick gets to h1
then it's going to be a big problem
ah king of sweet awesome I was thinking
of a king g3 first wow wow so is this
picking up the pawn or no wow you're
strong he sees these tactics to defend
these pawns technically just just
immediately so white resigns here
because King e1 wouldn't be met with
York g1 yes and it's simply checkmate
three two one well that honestly that
those last three moves we're like
incredibly yeah Bobby just like yeah of
course you can't take the pawn because
there's King III was 53 you're York g1
it's me this is really interesting so
one thing that I was trying I'm still
trying to work on and I've been telling
my students or teammates to do is for
example I think that the difference
between levels it's not just I mean if
you go even if you're stronger than your
opponent by hundreds or 200 points or
something and you go in the game and you
just make good moves
what's your opponent don't has only
moves he's gonna find them
yeah but like in this situation he
didn't have there was nothing moves
Bobby gave the opponent to make mistakes
gave the chance it's for opponents to
you know mess it up a little yeah but
you know in this type of position where
inevitability is kind of on your side
right you have this H pawn if white does
nothing then the H pawns just gonna go
up the board yeah right so you say to
white well pick your defense how do you
want to try to stop my HP pawn and then
if you choose wrong you're gonna lose
the game no but like yes but what I'm
trying to say is like the mustafa-bhai
did weren't all forceful yeah of course
he was more like because for example
here he had the chance to
please let's say kingi treat yeah King
Street there's the check for right you
know it comes very naturally but instead
you see just a little bit of demo set
which creates opportunities for the
opponents to make mistakes right so you
have three daring what during way to
take this pawn and then of course that
there was the well calculating follow-up
yeah exactly seeing it could simply go
to g3 keep the pond and well actually I
don't think you can go to g3 okay so you
cheat once again if you're just joining
us we'll introduce ourselves once again
my name is Caleb Denby and this is of
course the wonderful International
Master Dorsett Derek Shawnee and we are
giving you the coverage of the first
match in the protest league here today
ya know we're all I'm very glad that the
games that this was really nice to see
the opening between the Leo me and
Takara was also interesting yeah and it
actually worked out quite well for a
Hikari oh yeah I'm like very good at
navigating these types of positions
where you know it's a little unclear
what the compensation is you have some
vague activity advantage yeah he handles
those types of positions quite quite
well I was trying to see maybe maybe
instead of maybe hey Clara outs outs
prepared Korean Lee maybe that was it
because around here it feels like see
any cars moves are pretty simple like
what you want it's pretty much only move
that's but keep the position going like
you're not gonna take you want the night
to take upon but you can't do it right
now cuz of the chicken by White Queen ya
know you're six checker oh yeah so you
can't take you want the night to be 85
but you can't make that happen right now
so what do you do you play with d8 it's
defending the Queen and put put put your
hook in the in a good position useful
position White has to my castle now you
take 95 attacking the Queen and 94 is
then the natural move to 93 Queen d3
you're upon up you want to exchange off
the Queen of course everything was so
logical logical going on
for black and Queen Sita was interesting
move you're just pushing for more you
want to try and put 93 I think yeah it
was it's the type of uncomfortable
position for for both sides kind of
right like well yeah her black can't
really develop the Kings side but
meanwhile white really can't develop the
rooks and the the dark square Bishop as
well is kind of stuck on the back rank
and you know Cara made better use of the
pieces that he did have out that than
William Lee did yeah so that was an
interesting one and then I'm very
curious to see what went wrong for Sam
seven in this game yeah because we
checked back in and we thought Dominguez
set a good position words and there next
time whoops tamika's was just simply
crushing so c4 was in fact his choice
which we were saying this isn't really a
move you ever want to play with white
here correct me if I'm wrong
well the thing is like if I was playing
this with White's I think I would go
with 96 and I would exchange off the
then I would go to the endgame and try
my chances there yeah and I think you're
you're kind of I think that is what Sam
was was calculating right he spent a ton
of time on this one was three minutes
yeah like three minutes on this move and
I I'm willing to bet he was calculating
96 and he found something he didn't like
I mean c4 looks more sharp and edgy and
chances and but I thought I don't think
that's a good position was falling for
chances for the wrong side I think it's
the problem so c4 was played and of
course black loves to open more files
yeah it's the waking white does get this
night to a very nice see Foursquare but
let's see how Dominguez made use of
these files Oh interesting
I have goes to e3 you protecting your
upon and aiming for f5 as well yeah g6
is very nice to take a laugh by nahi
alright the bishop did come from g2
indeed see I was thinking maybe
something like Bishop c4 could be played
because if the bishop is on c4 and then
you could put the bishop on that side b3
and it's good protecting materia
but yeah that's interesting I have
thought maybe uh maybe a pond would
would like to come to b3 to support c4 a
little bit more concretely so then I
could come back to C for it and kind of
have an outpost that I know I know
of course though whenever you play b3
you're allowing for a5 a4
yeah also there is the problem with E
for looks if you play b3 there's always
as ephors on the nights we're trying to
relocate the ship would cook lipsticks
that is yeah quite quite dangerous so
let's see how they oh can you faith make
sense tonight goes to g4 you gotta get
that push up with this diagonal somehow
thanks to the trade and yeah f5 so this
this looks a little bit a little bit
desperate from Sam actually I think he
got the sense he needed to attack the
black king but he's giving up quite a
lot to do it right there's only one
minor piece left on the board and I
think this F pawn it doesn't doesn't
feel quite right yeah I agree that
that's conclusion specifically yes sorry
go ahead
no no I'm sorry I was just trying to say
maybe it's about time to try and well oh
that's enough of that I guess the next
round is I was just gonna mention that
the remaining bishops really seem to
favor black yeah it was gonna come to f6
and then attack the BT upon and it's a
clear path yeah it's better King safety
more pawns better pieces it was
everything that Dominguez needed oh we
got a car is missing yeah so every game
of Hikaru's is gonna be very very
important for the marshals a car really
needs to run up a big score for the
marshals to have a chance here and so we
see an e4 e5 and I think all of the
games yeah they all just started its the
knight c3 is this business right I
remember that was I had a WDM alarm game
there was a big day man it to win and I
was playing get lower into the opponents
yeah and she was from China and for the
first time in my life
you know in a classic just I saw this
the e4 e5 Knight c3 Knight and that at
least g6g tree and I was like for the
life of me worried trying to do and it
says oh yeah that's game didn't go my
way
well yeah I'm totally familiar with this
opening but I do think I've seen it once
or twice talking to a couple friends of
mine and it looks as though the point is
for white you get this nice Bishop on g2
the diagonal used to be closed
now that d5 has been played in this
these funds have been exchanged the
bishops open and there's some
uncomfortable pressure on the Queen side
right yeah
special hits the knight on c6 which
isn't really where it wants to be an
opponent b7 as well exactly
but of course that's not to say Wesley
has a bad position this is a very I
think this is a comfortable position
yeah I'm just my memories of and this
line keeps popping up I did mmm
I did play against Ralph Mamedov she was
- 615 and it was a first round of I
think oh ain't open something like that
114 and um I was just the W I am back
then and um I got two I was paired again
same black first round I was like damn
he's gonna play that again yeah this is
a very very tricky deceptively tricky
line from well yeah I came up with this
weird ideas of playing aged five and
that game ended in a draw so it's there
go check it that's interesting yeah it
was very interesting
Oh once again I want to say a quick
hello to Greg Shehadeh commissioner of
the protest I think he's joining us in
the chat for just a moment here hi
of course we're keeping an eye on the
Saqqara not Americans this is really I
think that the pivotal ones for the New
York marshals if they want to challenge
that the the thing that was Archbishop
they need a carro to perform quite quite
well
well it's take a look at I want to say
fabi's game yeah and well everybody
wants to see Bobby's getting old
I mean he's local he's he's the best yes
my he's my words for winning candidate
championship yes and this is another
very interesting position that it looks
like a rose out of an e 45 opening I
loved before
ah good old Lopez yeah yeah Bobby taking
it taking classical Roy I promise yeah I
feel like the just maturity and
understanding specially note in am
opening like Lopez really really matters
and it's not just about moves or like
ideas right so I I think he's got it
yeah my feeling of openings like the red
Lopez is you know even from a player of
like my level your level watching twenty
eight hundreds play it it can be very
very mysterious yeah right they're
making very important decisions you know
when I should play this piece here and
you know the order of moves becomes very
important the efficiency becomes very
important and if you're not careful
playing one of these guys you uh you
just get destroyed and you don't know
how yeah and so I think it's a very good
opening choice for Fabi it allows him to
show the younger Sam seven what he knows
about the oldest opening and chests and
really prove a really proven advantage
yeah I find this is such a logical
position and like you just it's not that
much that you have to calculate more is
you have to know and you have to have
the instincts and things like that um
I'm gonna be was a little bit more time
before I begin I think Sam solution is
totally fine here yeah yeah one thing to
look out for those you know there's a
very natural plan of bringing a knight
in to f5 this is always gonna be a big
threat to look out for if you're playing
with the black pieces for the moment it
seems to be under control anymore most
things might go wrong
I was thinking about this I don't play
this opening as whites all the time I've
given it some few tries and I still do
it from London but I always remember
that I saw games that you would do this
weird like King moves on Ice Age 2 I'm
like h1 and there's stuff like that and
you try that open for f4 and like a no I
hope the game's gonna go that high yes
we actually seen d63 it's a very
interesting decision from from Sam here
he opens up the D file letting him look
at this Digimon but it does give white
some more control over the center right
agree and perhaps actually I think an
interesting movie might be before it's
the same size that's what I was thinking
about cuz if you did before you're
trying to expose a little bit more the
d4 square but I'm curious though can you
respond to be for maybe with d4 oh okay
and we actually I think we see Bishop
takes b3 for that purpose cuz d4 would
be threatening d5 yes with some ideas of
you know maybe a fork but neither fly
the score is kind of yeah but like I
mentioned we do see now a knight f5 yeah
this is gonna be a pretty big problem I
think for Sam I think so too I like
white yeah I do like white there is a
very natural plan for black though
before is I think the key move yes you
want to shake loose White's control of
the d4 square and then plant your knight
on that square and find activity in that
way uh wedding
yeah so we do cp4 and now how do you
want to respond to this says as white
it's a little unclear to name I'm kind
of in love with this idea of playing d4
in response but I don't think it's fun I
think - I was thinking about the d4 you
can just simply take back yeah so
there's a common idea when you have a
pawn Center like this where d4 would be
a very great outpost for a piece yes
sometimes you want to play deep or
forcing a pawn to capture and then that
piece that Square is no longer available
to the pieces in this case though if you
play d4 why can capture and then push
the pawn to d3 and so the top queen of
fine was there because of the pen but
yes as well simply not gonna work though
and now I think Bobby is have actually
happy to trade these Knights
whoa twelve c5 not a move I stopped
coming
that's huh that's weird then I was kind
of aching for q4g for it I think it's
very the problem is maybe g4 was good
chances of ninety six on the night if
nice going to f4 maybe that's with be a
little bit so maybe you can see a night
after the the trade of the Knights maybe
then g4 because they weren't realistic
no obvious questioning where you want to
put your Bishop cuz the bishop can't
stand yeah you have to play Bishop d6
right otherwise or it takes e5 there's a
d4 works to buy 54 I think night five
might my capture and then the rook can
kind of swing to the Kings side and the
pawn on d4 is gonna be very very bad
movie night at five now you know 35 hmm
it looks windy six
with an Brooke c1 and the c7 fun is kind
of well I'm sorry I'm a big 96 he said I
was thinking if 95 rook c5 you would do
something like Queen these seats and
attack the roof there's just Rick t5
though right and then there may be queen
bee seeks to keep attacking the rook but
then there is a rook c1 yes kind of
thunder under attack sequence we b6 I
think this is a good good try from from
Sam he still wants to take on a5 there's
a kind of five is kind of yeah it might
be time for Fabi to actually play Knight
takes ISA I think so too
cuz if not out the Knights high five is
coming and the pawn structure would be
kind of a maybe has other things in mind
though you never know you know we hope
it's slowly Ricky - so this is
interesting
so he's allowing black to capture on f5
in the hopes that I guess maybe this and
I could come to e4 yeah thank you very
very nasty f6 threat but if yeah if
Queen d6 then how are you gonna you
maybe just take the time player if d1 or
d2 but then you wouldn't be able to put
the knight on e4 uh okay yeah that's a
good point I think maybe Brooke c2 comes
to mind as well Oh defending tactically
nice
I think maybe let's take a look at
another game yes I know this games very
very interesting but of course there are
three other games let's take a look at
say cars game oh wow
it develops really fast yes so it looks
as though something white is a pawn to
the good but the structure is quite
fractured I think honestly I quite like
Wesley's position here not to play for a
win but perhaps for it for a half point
ok my suggest my prediction of this game
will in the draw in fact I think if
anybody is better I actually do you
think it's Wesley here mm-hmm
so the bishop on the c7 is attacked but
that's not actually the real threat here
I think the threat is Bishop takes C -
yeah and so almost no matter what white
does I think you can still play Bishop
c2 if you try to defend with Ricky - you
can still actually capture because the
Brook takes bishop you ever takes bishop
with less and if you play Bishop d6 y
can play tricky east fix still keeping
the thread on the bishop and yeah Bishop
c2 is simply coming yeah I agree
let's take a look at Dominguez game I
don't think the look that just so far
yeah I think that's the new one so
Dominguez now playing board for the New
York marshals so this would be an
interesting one to look out for and okay
we're taking a look at the opening but
the current position there's a current
there's a move just like screaming to be
played but um okay so so far I like
White's the structure White's pawn
structures of screaming France hawk on
the Kings side of course very good
enough for us coming and now he's gonna
H fun getting involved as well oh my god
this is so nice yeah Wow this you see
one
and so bishops you know after the next
move for c8 I mean everybody wants to
play rook takes d5 but I don't think
grace
there's simply d4 this was the move that
I was talking about but it doesn't work
at all
I think what if this g4 nah yeah g4 g4
is very nice
z4 there must be some way to try to worm
your way into the end of the dark
squares on this Kings side yeah Damini
was thinking so much
yeah I think this is a very important
position white does seem to have an edge
in time on the Kings side right the
pawns have already been pushed
weaknesses have been made but now you
get to this point and it's a little
unclear how you actually kind of rip it
open
yeah you'd love to play a move like f5
eventually but the current problem is
you leave the e5 pawn behind so if you
want to play you know g4 and f5 you you
somehow have to defend the e5 pawn and
d4 for black is is coming very naturally
and after c-4 in d3 okay so you exchange
off the bishops well the thing is if now
d4 there's always been Queen c4 yeah
Queens before it'd be very nice to kind
of blockade others of course you know
Knight b6 though coming coming
eventually to to force that Queen from
it's out first I'm thinking where you
want to have this c1 to Shep are you
gonna try and play Petrie Bishop b2
I think it's fine on c1 it's it is
serving a purpose defending the king and
while it may not be the greatest
attacker I don't know if it's totally
necessary the the pawns are kind of
serving the role of a dark square Bishop
yeah I think I think this okay I would
honestly route it to be whites in this
position so just because I can't find
the exact yes you get the feeling white
should have something maybe there's
still a matter of finding it and why
don't we take a quick look at the last
game
liyan leaned against hussain huh what
what's going on here it looks as though
some type of you know but no nice one -
oh nice tile I just see weakness d6
opponent always think benoni but we do
have this imbalance where black has a
weak d6 pawn but white actually hasn't I
would call d5 a weakness as well and
it's gonna be a question of which
weakness can be a kind of attacked more
effectively and now we see rook c4 I
think I'm a fan of blacks position here
yeah I think books are gonna be more
active I think so too let's take a quick
look it's how the opening everybody
played efore thank you yeah of course
good old Berlin all right the opening
[ __ ] c5 yes yeah it's interesting
and then that that's how we ended up
with the banana pounce troopers well not
not quite because the the pawn is still
on g7 yeah kind of kind of backtrack man
I did sure tonight smooth no life d4 a
94 would have been would have been
interesting but maybe uh feels not a
trapped yeah maybe you don't actually
want to block off here at your dark
square bishop maybe these threats on the
c3 are gonna be important and so this
night can come back to g6 and actually
have an e5 square alright yeah I like
the idea see a trade of Queens and now
yeah f4 from White was played well you
went through it very quickly but I think
that's kind of an important decision
here yes the Queen the Queen trade and
then f4 for white I actually don't
really like that move before yeah what
what does he do it makes weaknesses for
white right I would have preferred some
simpler way to just develop the pieces
maybe Bishop e3 here we to palm yeah
there's there's your could be 1 and b7
might be on under some pressure
alright maybe technically that's not
quite working but but f4 seems very
recommittal but okay so I agree yeah
maybe I for was to to avoid the 96-95
ideas uh yeah but now I think I think
black is pretty comfortable f4 is the
second secondary weakness that really
kind of tips tips is over the edge yeah
I agree
okay so the shows are exchanged off very
simple is going for that you know and f4
is really not what you want in this I'm
game why it would much prefer to have
the pawn on f2 so the second-ranked is a
lot more defended and you don't have to
worry quite so much about the rooks
invading
hmm this is a good Duns game to play as
black yeah I very much like blacks
chances here I think maybe you can
expand on the queenside even a little
bit further with black although you
don't want to be too hasty with it and
then yeah it's you know defy this week
maybe you can argue you know there's
gonna be some Nevis azan on p2 as well
for sure black black for choice but you
know maybe I can hold yes
okay let's take a look at Bobby yes some
very big developments that would made so
we were talking earlier about a night
moving to e4 and then the plum coming to
f6 and it looks like Bobby has achieved
just that but isn't there one less ball
yeah I think we were somewhere here when
we left off yes so right after c4 and
then c5 yeah we did see this trade yes
Bobby just gives up this pawn in order
to achieve this night on the e4 square
and eventually has to give in mm-hmm
probably playing very slowly just
advancing on on the kingside yeah and
while h5 okay really interesting what
and we do see f6 now in King age 7 and
then I streets you just get the Knights
more protected yeah we do see a trade of
rooks and and another trader Brooks
being offered and Bobby is going for an
endgame and of course if you count the
pawns
Bobby is is down upon but more important
than the pawns in the endgame is almost
always the activity yeah specifically
the King activity there's nothing for
black to activate his King or even to
try and get these pieces in a better
place so so we go for the pure endgame
now and after some exchanges of course
as black you you want to play King g82
f8 to EA to d7 and then you're in the
game right but it's it's unfortunately
not so easy to achieve because you're
leaving behind for example a weak h6
pawn and if I H pawn ever falls then I
think white is gonna just the problem is
right now black would want to play
something like Bishop d8 9x bishop d8 94
c4 yeah that is that is a good point
let's see maybe uh maybe you play Knight
c4 here should be a bishop d8 I just
want to take your epon take on it
yep six yeah then I don't know if I
actually have time to to play Knight
takes f7 I don't think it's a seafood it
looks looks quite dangerous
yeah what's the O 5 wants to deal with
this this
a little problematic wasn't the king g3
okay Bishop the agent
yeah maybe 94 and he just takes Sifu
okay so once again Bobby
I said earlier T activity is important
he's giving up that the f6 pawn and just
running the King King g7 I think yeah
maybe that Knight e4 you can play c4
maybe you can know that that looked very
dangerous
I can't breathe interesting maybe we
have six time
well f6 King e6 yeah I think things
might be going no that's going the right
direction for Fabi
okay camps it's yeah king of six and
then maybe even king e7 I'm trying to
promote the king yeah yeah score you
know that's going a touchdown nothing I
can go that deep because there's always
the f5 any force right there's there is
some danger so okay I'll I'll ask the
question let's say King f6 King g8 and
then I start passing I think you know 92
94 and IP to 94 what is what is blacks
plan - it's nothing I don't think black
has a clear winning so that's that's the
good news for Fabi
it has two pawns to the good but the
pawns are situated in such a way that if
Bobby can maintain this light square
blockade on the Queen side and have this
this King sitting very nicely on the F
file I think there's no real danger for
him of course I could always be wrong on
that side no I think you're right in the
situation I think this game is a draw
okay let's take a look at T car oh yes
and wow I think this has gone very very
well for Wesley
we were talking about how there was some
Bishop c2 threats the last time we left
off and it looks like that didn't
actually come to fruition
I think we were we were somewhere maybe
here uh you know not quite so far back
yeah I think we saw Bishop c7 yeah we
were right here and so Bishop d6 turkey
six push it back to c7 and now Wesley
brings things the King forward and we
actually see a trade of the bishop for
the night a very interesting decision
Wow
yeah I I can't explain it should take
she to like uh maybe Wesley knows
something I don't
in fact maybe he knows many many things
no I think this is good yeah I mean the
positions can work out for them but then
start pushing those maybe Queens so yeah
Wesley up upon getting the majority
rolling and now this is our current
position and cart down to 30 seconds
Leslie at a minute 15 and yeah so so
Homer I was gonna have to hope that this
this Jeep on will be worth both of the
pawns on the the Queen side I mean it's
not like as much other choice ya know
that this is this is what he has to play
for and now of course the bishop on b2
making use of the long-range powers of
the bishop right that's why in these end
games bishops are generally more
favorable than Knights because they can
blockade on one side of the board and
support the advance of the pawns on the
other however in this case well first of
all night takes up five looks like a
pond like what am i what am I missing
and play your ex situ first if he even
want just just Knight a5 right simply
Knight a5 and maybe there is a no this
is this is just over this step I was
thinking maybe there's a noticing
electric gift tree but that feels like
meat yeah a knight Knight
c4 the bishops under threat before
there's no more checks where do you put
this the ship that's the thief shall we
have the results and sodium leak did
manage to draw his position against me
say no we we kind of like this position
a bit more but a draw is a perfectly
fine result for a bird board for yeah
this is what this game was in hmm oh we
have the resultant car would just simply
resigned here of course you know you you
have to stop rook e1 checkmate the only
way to do that is to play Bishop C 3 by
C to play Bishop c3 there's your key to
picking up the fish
ya know I like this position it's very
interesting so now we have the Ross on
winning I think this game well so this
is Bobby's game this is the one that
that's looking kind of dangerous in fact
the the black King made it a lot further
than I ever thought it would and now now
I'm beginning to think that this is this
one's going to just be a loss yeah
simply king d3 I think it gets here
because we were looking at this position
King Kane so yeah I thought King f6
would have been a move or move but it
looks like with the bishop on d4 there's
gonna be this eve or check if you ever
do bring the skin - well that's the
thing in this situation we thought after
94 Bishop a4 this this is one we wanted
to play King in for here maybe it would
have been a little bit of a better try
actually but but I think eventually you
would really run out of booze cuz can
get 6 PG aids yeah I do want to mention
though uh Linnaean Dominguez was up a
clear exchange in his game and he did
actually just convert that to a winning
King and pawn endgame so that's that's
another win for us all right so we won
the match and so we want well we was
around we won the round with a full two
and a half points to our name already it
doesn't matter the results of this last
game what it does matter of course but
nothing we are still scoring positive
yeah and it looks as though Fabi did
actually just just resign this position
well I have to give it to the center
didn't he bowed very low very very well
done Fabi giving up some some ponds and
then going into the sudden game it just
didn't really materialize have anything
no there are the shore house with what
to think of the game I mean I don't
think there was any point that there was
a clear path to white what to do so it
was this decision I think to alumni
takes f5 that looked a little bit
strange to us right yes allowing out of
5 when you wait could have just played
night 97
so yeah these in between moves were
pretty interesting but especially here
simply night 67 is is totally playable I
think well the problem is if you just do
97 let's say rookie 7 you gotta move the
rook and then the Brooks will double to
d5 this is a D file I'll try and I'm not
sure it's so simple right I wanted to
play 97 in rookie 7 and then Rick FA one
time I wanted to find some counterpoint
there's the your pawns hanging is it
maybe it is that's so sad
yeah I think we actually do have a
scoreboard with the results on it so why
don't we take a quick look at how we're
doing here
so of course in this second round we had
Cara Nakamura losing to Wesley so a huge
victory for Wesley
Liam Lee drew Agadir to sign off Fabi
goes down to Sam setting and a massive
upset and Lenny in dominguez does win
against the Marshalls board former end
up this brings the total match score to
five and a half to two and a half well
it could be better but it could be
better but plus three after two minutes
I mean even if it's not the even if
we're not winning all of our favorable
matchups it's it's more than enough for
two runs of course eight-and-a-half is
the magic number eight and a half out of
sixteen means we win the match and get
10 extra points to your name but really
we're going for more we're going for it
it should be a hard job to just get
three more points to be honest but I
agree the more you get the better and in
fact it's almost unimaginable that this
team couldn't score three points in two
rounds of course you know every point
counts towards towards your standings in
the regular season so there's no reason
to let off the gas even if we do get to
eight and a half but the Marshalls kind
of fighting for their life here already
well there there was this big upset with
Bobby you know I think even the [ __ ]
upset was was a bigger deal I needed a
car would it be scoring three three and
a half four
points in this game to have any chance
yeah of doing some damage to this
Archbishop's team so which of these
games didn't we yeah why don't we see
how Dominguez managed to convert that
game because we we liked his position
but weren't sure how he was gonna break
through it looks so long ago apparently
yeah we left off somewhere this exact
official traded in g4 was played
so yeah black players Erick b61 yes sir
he won of course defending the epon
preparing this f5 push you have to play
the d4 let's go the other way
yeah maybe Queen g3 was was natural to
defend life and also Queens c4 it
doesn't make so much sense because there
could be four it is possible okay Queen
c63 quick c6 f5 all right yeah and you
take g6 now there's an open up fighting
from g3 okay trick if one yeah
rook f8 and rook b8 is something you'd
love to see his white here why kind of
abandoning his attack in defense of his
own okay exactly okay fine was really
interesting maybe I because I thought
maybe there could be something with
Queen e5 but it should there shouldn't
be one psyche when you finally you can I
just play real cafes King f8 recap on
King you has to go back to g8 right and
Queen f3 probably yeah quit f3 just
looks dominating on the nobody stop
Queen f7 yeah so Rick f1 we're back to
the 8th and this queen is trying to
invade
and night five looks quite dangerous
though Queen seven in that of sevens
forced is in there so there's there's
Queen f6 but I guess 96-86 I mean okay
one should be good enough to yeah just a
simple chest five why not see five here
interesting
what's the point of G five I guess are
you making a threat
mm-hmm yeah III don't know
I would have expected more or something
along lines of maybe like Rick f6 trying
to get the second drunk into the game
Queen h4 does seem a little bit odd but
you know weird up for dominguez yeah see
how they yeah I don't see it seems like
black made quite a bit of progress
already
and well so he's still going in man this
is maybe this one was quite fortunate
yes
well now there's arcanine yeah yeah
there is an attack but I mean black
spawn groups so strong
yeah all of a sudden though there's
nothing yeah this this I can see mister
takes be a yes simply winning the
exchange and then he did a very nice job
to to convert this endgame it looks like
yeah this this should be hard to I mean
you still need to yeah I mean there's
always a to the look out for but if you
keep that under control then huh yeah
you're just gonna try and hook up the
pawns and just pick up your other pawns
so Lenny ain't managing to convert the
son game why don't we take a quick look
at the Round three pairings and see what
the matchups look like for us going
forward
Lenny evening is has his turn against
the New York Marshal's board one Curran
Nakamura Bobby is playing a goose a
Knopf on oh well I guess board one
report to it it all gets a little
confused
Sam 7 is against Liam Lee and Miranda is
against Wesley so so of course the
matchups to look out for
Cara once again needs to start scoring
more points for the marshals to have any
chance in this match and Lenny a with
the white pieces will be looking to shut
him down once again Bobby will be
looking to get back on form again it's
gonna say Tom after that tough loss the
same 7 and once again we need three more
points to clinch the match with two
rounds to do it it shouldn't be too hard
arty and it looks like we're just about
underway here we have Millennia's game
of against a card Nakamura
first off with one efore
[Music]
who do you think will get this screen
hahaha that's a good question
once again Hikaru is a very very strong
legendary online player and so you can
never really discount his chances it's
tough to say that anybody's the favorite
against him besides me being players
like Bobby but Lenny and Dominguez you
know a very strong rapid and blitz
player he's been playing especially
these these world-class st. Louis
trapping the Bloods events for some time
now and I expect him to do pretty well
with the white pieces all right I'm a
big fan of Italian but this a 5 it is
out of my comfort zone yes so a six is
more normal and then I think in recent
years especially in the World
Championship match between Bobby Magnus
you saw a force not as far as that's
yeah a force and especially before from
White was a way that White was gaining
space so perhaps a f5 is aimed a little
bit at shutting down that plan of
gaining so much space on the Queen side
hitting that uncomfortable pressure I
think a 5 is interesting but I think the
problem is that when you play a 5
actually the thing is might become a
little dangerous if they can get the
chance to play 90 floors right next
before is a very natural outpost and
then you're adding another target along
along with the Bishop that the pawn will
also be slightly weak although it's
still a very normal position here for
both players you know there's always
these ideas of playing d4 or playing d5
of course the knight from d2 can
transfer itself to gingery looking at
that at 5 squared like we saw in Bobby's
game however I do like the way in at
blacks position is right now
uh-1 I think this is this is a pretty
normal Italian position yeah I'm not
sure if there's too much going on here
that's that's out of the ordinary just
agree I mean that depends waters words
boyfriend - maybe the my c7 like g6 idea
or trying to push d5 you know with Ricky
it I think he's telegraphing that that
this D again is a little bit more normal
and Caro does I say that quite quickly
and I think you have to recapture with
the Queen or the bishop here to make
sure that pawn stays defended and after
Queen takes do you run into some trouble
we takes there's I'm tough to exploit
others later like Bishop III but I'm not
sure it's really amounting to anything
maybe 93 in 93 I was a cadet g3 actually
in 93 is a tempting tempo gainer but
really for is the square this Knight
wants to be on so g3 is routing it
towards towards that home great all
right let's take another look at who do
you want to see puppy oh yeah we can we
can take a look at fabi's game all right
wow that was fast
Wow they have they have washed
themselves into this militant position
in my Roxy so yeah it's a you 45 and we
see another another rendition wow this
is open yeah
Queens everything is pretty typical you
get the Queen's oh let me see 94 96 all
all the maneuvers we saw in the previous
game and yeah f5 once again gets played
but and this is committed to g4 yeah
she's very interesting so what was
fabi's point machee for actually this
point was to play g5 Fantas probably
start pushing the edge spawn yeah well I
think I mean if you get f4 and you got
the rich pawn to h6 that Bishop is kind
of like looks like a pancake yeah I
think jihad is actually very very
interesting move I like it yeah a lot of
the times you'll see a white do these
pawn storms with the Queens on the board
trying to checkmate black but in this
case it can actually be a very very
valuable asset in the endgame if you get
this pawn to g5 and h5 there's always a
threat of making a past H pawn very very
quickly and that's going to maybe you
know prevent some of the black pieces
from coming to the center we'll have to
keep an eye on this
Kings side for Fabi and now that t5 has
been played Bobby has to make a decision
whether or not to open the center with
with plan takes you know so how do you
keep things close though I'm not totally
sure I just feel like it's not ready to
the centers not ready to be open the
other four white yeah there's the snake
on a four that isn't actually making the
greatest impression
maybe we'll see another ninety six
getting getting these nights off the
board and kind of getting this Bishop to
b6 allowing for the e3 square for maybe
for the king and allowing you know the
risk to come to the D file you know
things to be a little bit more
comfortable for the way yeah I agree
this game is back in the lab but more
interesting than I thought it was yeah
I'm not actually totally sure what to
think about about Bobby's position here
so you're simply Rick hd1 bring your to
the center is never a bad plan well I
mean the your pawn structure could be
affected because right now you can take
it I think yeah you can take it
whoa yeah yes I agree I don't know
I don't think that structure is so bad
though for white if pawn takes I think
politics immediately yeah that's what
happened
and now if this pawn gets to c5 as it
should eventually it could also be
creating some threats and while you
might think see c4 is a big weakness b7
is now also a weakness to look out for
as a root come to that opened the earth
a have opened a file to put some
pressure yeah alright let's give this
game a little bit of time man let's look
at I'm gonna get a car okay and so we
left off somewhere around I want to see
here yeah deep silence we get in a
cherry tree let like we said now that
the e4 pawn is gone before it becomes a
very nice outpost for the pieces yeah
Dominguez just spend about two and a
half minutes thinking about that D -
interesting
simply earthy eight and no Queen f3 if
I'm Dominguez here I really want to put
a knight on right Foursquare I don't I
don't know what the delay really is then
will there could be at five yeah it's
just some have five so perhaps you know
like Knight takes Knight and then if you
play Knight takes Knight
there's f5 to consider no I'm not I'm
not totally sure about that plan for for
black it does seem don't seem like the
right idea to gain some space in this
manner but so you do have to be slightly
worried about the King site structure
falling apart I agree I think they both
have good fighting chances like teams
pick a favorite in the position just yet
cuz I kind of messy chances are both
sides and yeah there's an interesting
idea maybe to play Knight h5 rather than
ie4 Oh might be a more favorable way to
trade off these Knights not yet
committing the knight to the e4 square
so if I wouldn't be coming with tempo
but state
yeah and then maybe something like Queen
g3 could follow and then after 94 you're
making a lot of threats of Knight f6
special takes h6 yeah I actually do like
that move
but yeah so Lenny eight does have some
decisions decisions to make in this game
all right let's go I'm like Liam Lee's
position actually it looks like it was
in English and Liam is is hoping to make
some threats on the light squares
opening okay so far symmetrical
yes mister coming out to my place
develop panic the rooks
trying to exchange off the bishops
alright look see every so far so and I
think all of the moves are logical it's
fairly standard white of course you know
in the symmetrical English he has the
slight advantage in time so he gets to
play this before idea a bit yeah
so Liam Lina adopted a more defensive
stance laughing so Florida so nice yes
so rather than try and meet white on the
Queen side with a 65 Leone plays b6 and
tries to find play on the Kings side and
that's exactly what he's doing I should
chief or oh my and the light squares are
really under fire now for uh okay this
is this has this pond can't just live
like this in fact I refuse to believe
that this way you ever kept a this was
plated and yeah how do you defend 95 why
can't two just play let's see he sees
yeah e6 looks looks totally normal
maybe even know it removing this night
from f6 first could be an option huh
playing some more like 98 just to be
very very mean and then I say six you
maybe it should be six me to e4 oh yeah
well the thing is if you like east seeks
I was thinking if they have six pinch of
f6 and after you just try and thank this
guy well the bishop has h3 but the move
I really want is is a move like 98 which
is simply saying I'm gonna play e6 next
turn and then
gonna have some serious problems
defending defending d3 so night h7 very
similar idea I think this moves better
than my move because now you're aiming
for more light squares on the Kings side
with Knight g5 but yeah II six is coming
d3 is falling I don't see what same
study and plans to do about it maybe
will will expect some d4 push trying to
to break open things but I guess there's
Bishop out five problems you're actually
activating the bishop on g7 the point is
you get to look into e7 perhaps
activating along the open e file but
you're giving up quite a lot if you play
d4 I feel like I like the idea of moving
the night and then thinking you had a
six I don't know that - yes yes and I
mean in 97 this is the perfect way to do
it yeah I think wife's got this a very
very good position for this thing boy
gets Leslie so I don't think we did look
at him before yeah this this game is new
wait a second I'm okay well them I'm
nothing is alright little the weird
grocer I tried to play this football
what's with these professional players
putting their knights on c6 I just never
felt like it's like I learned it for so
long I gave it a few tries and it does
just not me okay so we CH 6 + e5 so once
again the point of putting the knight on
c6 is you have this extra control of the
ephah yeah so if you can break through
with E 5 it's usually worth it take take
take take and oh submission of entries
awesome some dangerous ideas white
wasn't fazed though alright yeah I don't
think it was quite working there's yeah
for ideas and the Queen defend of the
long second rank
all right so it's d8 yeah this is an
interesting idea actually offering up to
rooks for the Queen actually yeah if 468
where to be played but I think that
would be pretty favorable for it for
black due to the bishops yep
so instead we saw Queen b3 and Nelson
please raid and this can't be worse for
black I don't think it can be better for
black in fact I think rook d7 would be a
pretty simple repetition
I believe so it's a cozy 47 you gotta
have to play rookie 70 because if people
eat b5 your pawns are all like holes
yeah you want to play if you wanted you
could actually play rook b8 though
and then King e8 would be evicting this
rook from d7 and perhaps this is what's
this idea we'll see a repetition first
but now I think rook be it is actually a
very very real move to consider the
other thing like we have two concerns my
our players don't have to like play
crazy well I would love crazy but they
don't have to kill themselves for a win
because we only need three points yeah
Oh JA offer was made and yes they
decline decline you love to see it and I
think I like this decision from Wesley
he isn't risking anything here yeah
white rook is being evicted from from
the seventh rank and definitely in the
black Bishop is better than the white
bishop here and you might expect Wesley
to expand on the Queen side now yeah
yeah stuff like a 5 a 4 C 5 C 4 I think
you should put the King on he has a 6
yeah and Wesley really doesn't have to
rush here he's got plenty of time the
dark squared Bishop 4 for white is going
to be kind of difficult to activate in
fact you might consider move f5 trying
to really keep this this Bishop locked
down interesting yeah because otherwise
I think white will something play e4 and
try to get the bishop into the game and
manner the other thing is sometimes you
just don't want to touch the minority
palms because if you do like effort with
create chances of I'm not sure if I'm
correct but that's a F for Bishop f6 G
for oh yeah
interesting yeah oh they went okay so he
went for rookies change and then decided
not to interesting that Wesley saw a
white commit to b3 and now he puts the
suddenly c5 and c4 it's because a very
real idea yeah all sort of thing is I
was gonna stay oh no a drunk was
actually agreed so it looks like looks
like Wesley decided enough was enough
yeah did take the draw here why don't we
jump back to a Carter's can because
they're still very early on because he's
getting into some serious time pressure
yes wait so you're you were mentioning
earlier one downside to putting this
poem on a5 is that one of night lands on
c4 is under pressure and we see just
that actually going on right in
predictions the ninth on GF I was kind
of really annoying though and it's going
to jump on e6 I'm come to a fourth yeah
I think I think this might might be
quite nice for a car ooh here actually
this Knight does come to e6 I'm gonna
say but I think you're right if maybe
there's Knight f5 94 and then queen g4
it's a trick yes queen g4 I think is
much much better way to do this so now
you can respond to Knight f4 with Knight
a5 and you've the dual threat of Queen
g7 hints and night age sex but there's
this Bishop d6 I'm using your you're
absolutely right yeah I don't think this
uh this game might be annoying and hard
for them in us to keep but I don't think
it's dangerous particularly right it
students be hard to keep draw that might
be wrong I agree
yeah know what is always finding counter
play right like yes nights coming to b5
where it attacks the slightly weak c7
pond and there's also going to be ideas
of the d4 breakthrough resolving all of
these issues for white if he can manage
to a test that move so in factor of d1
defends the pond and supports supports
d4 as well and they could be maybe some
ninety fours and I see five yeah yeah
I'm I'm hopeful he's like I lose this
game alright let's check out yeah father
yeah seems to be quite far advanced well
six minutes endgame so hold on the games
are 10 minutes and Bobby's up five
minutes yes it's of course game in ton
with a two second date that's Bobby
moving in quite quite quickly and I
think in this game quite well I think he
has good chances here there's a 96 check
know that you have to be careful of
there's also maybe some even Knight f6
could be played working the bishop in
the pawn on h7 that f6 looks kind of
powerful actually they agree and then
there's seven pawn is kind of them in
the wind
yeah unless there's some move with a
chance
that's a black page right well the
problem is a few point like night this
okay there's this Rupert g2 and then the
Bishop f4 is kind of coming ok the d5
Bishop is under attack what yeah all
pieces hanging
everything is on the outside man Demitra
Komarov is say say it's simply Bishop c6
and now there's still this threat of a
virtue to to look out for in fact why
not play a move like mmm and stuff I
want to find some way to stop the search
g2 idea maybe Bishop h3 but it doesn't
seem very very natural there's there's
Rick III check then
so what if we simply take on H 796 HSN
and how does the line go
did you Eric G to King H 3 bishop for
and then G 6 check I think looks quite
strong now e7 is falling yeah King no
idea where I want to say e8 okay can you
8 maybe it wasn't 67 maybe that's seven
in the Newark CA dose is you can the
shows on that fourth whoops
oh you're right I don't know this it
feels like everything's gonna be
resolved in the next few moves and
fortunately for Fabi he has half his
time to figure it out whereas I know
it's kind of kind of just going with the
flow here the thing is Rita is kind of
the only threat that black cast so I'm
gonna try and find a way to just
dissolve it it's it's difficult it's
difficult
well maybe 94 I know I was kind of
hopeful about my dish six ah yeah well I
think we should actually let Bobby
figure this one out yes I think Liam
leave position is is I would call it
crushing oh yeah he's gonna win this
game
yeah yeah that soon it's gonna be a
question yeah but the two bishops and
the strong eat pawns now and the time
and the time difference bishops III is
an interesting try trying to actually
win this a pawn back
but for Celia my husband and mind you
feels suspicious I think you have to you
can't have to play Queen D tree yeah
Queen d3 I suppose the idea is it's
Knight takes e5 well that's mighty fine
you can just feels like something should
be hanging in the air
thanks but maybe it's it's not the thing
is if 95 we should be fed we should be v
queen bee tree rook Petri Bishop d3
maybe or rook tea tree and then you if
the roofs get exchanged then you're
attacking the c4 pawn yeah but you know
that it is opposite yeah it's not so
simple to win maybe just a little too
early is there is there any other any
other line though for for white I really
don't see
oh this guy's oh my god here's two
seconds now I want to make it down to
two seconds to know all the puns are
falling this is yeah this one looks like
a Hikaru is is taking home another win
for the New York Marshalls unfortunately
oh hey car is the best player Oh is
there it takes me six no there's not
that would be awesome there is works III
though trying to hold it hold it all
together I don't think that's realistic
to be honest no this this is this is
just it for a380 the game the game will
be ending let's take another look at
Bobby who's saying Ah this whoa hold on
what happened all right so c7 was played
after two 1/2 minutes of thinking like
this J to King Street eek oh wow this is
crazy it takes and maybe politics is as
Bobby's idea
I wish right now if you play Rick takes
there's no way to defend to the Fen g5
here just you're admitting to a draw
there yeah but if you play pawn takes
maybe you can you can pretend you have
you have something but I'm not sure I
see it I okay the king
oh I'm sorry I think the King is a
little too cut off to realistic Bishop
g4 right oh I guess there's our case
your h1 I just you need to check this
this came off of f7 somehow yes it's not
not possible uh or you can just exchange
off or just try to win on time if you're
Fabiana Carolina good to check whoa whoa
I don't know about King g7 can eat seven
looks possibly now we're getting
recognition isn't rook and with so
little time on the clock I think this is
actually very very decent winning
chances
right I agree yeah this this well the
king is still pretty cut off coming
forward I don't think you can keep the
king cut off with the bishop on the
board the bishop can always block the
file and then yeah you can slowly
advance and no simply your case six
picks up is this final pawn
whenever Fabia wants it right okay uh
yeah yeah I think well okay this is a
two results game this shouldn't really
be worried about it ya know why don't we
check out the the final game still in
action and carb did manage to convert I
can say to me yes why don't we see how
BM Lee is faring in Sam seve and it
looks like the complications very much
worked out in the Emily's favor here
this should just be a winning rope end
game yeah this is shouldn't be dangerous
at all yeah this where it comes to a 1
now and the a pond will fall Oh even c4
and just this rook is trapped oh yeah
come to be far and then rook takes rook
takes a 3 check and now oh oh wait maybe
that was a slip actually I don't know
well King g5 would be coming into it I
mean this should be winning regardless
yes it is
there's nothing nothing to be oh damn
that was nice
yeah of course it's Ricky for there's
that five check and that would spell
doom and Liam Lee wins on time thanks
Lionel in game in this round is this
game between Fabiana Cara Juana and
Qadir who sign of where Bobby has
recognition against rook and we'll see
if he manages to convert this
now I don't know about about yourself
but I'm not up to date on my road
condition purses room I think this is
all gonna look a little bit like random
new ring to most eyes including my own I
think in general the idea is you need to
pin the King to the back rank yes you
need to have the bishop position so that
you can effectively block checks from
from the rook and the problem with this
is always first of all getting the King
to the back rank and then secondly
keeping this rook from from causing too
much trouble for you I agree well the
thing is okay I would like to assume
that the super grandmasters would know
what they're doing yeah but there's
always math sleep there's always some
cool cute brothers right and you see
this Bishop on g4 actually very nicely
placed controls the d1 square for the
moment and now after Bishop e1 I can go
50 from the dark square get it checked
and you see the King and the bishop
working together to really cut off all
squares on the sixth rank and only then
will this rip come to the seventh
pushing the King further back
ah King f6 is nice can't take the chance
do you check that and there should be
six King deviates rook seven oh it's
that just winning sufficient b6 candy
eight rookies seven yeah you have to
place some Rick move I suppose yep
but then there's Rick d7 Oryx c7 as a
threat so I guess c5 is forced Erica c5
is played but now there's it's so close
it's supposed to being being great wait
there's Rick d6 with the bishop f7
threat well yeah well hold on it does
some 36 I think wins yeah
wait 30 60 7 this is 7 fish about 500
cases Oh Rick a 6 here you better is it
glass sometime yeah when by timeout I
should even though Yannick was somehow
someway it Bobby bring from the full
point well this is really interesting
match let's take a very very short break
because they're gonna start soon again
yeah absolutely
before we could take the break maybe we
could see how much the points you're up
now yes so he's scored time in half and
then we got two and a half now so we are
all ready so we're at 8 so we've
clinched this attire we need a half
point out of 4 in the final round didn't
be a hard thing to do so looking very
good we'll be back in very short few
minutes yeah be sure to join us for more
live coverage of round 3 of the protest
League match yeah alright see you soon
when you visit st. Louis you probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game
back to the hotel would be a major error
sted boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us
you guys know I can't play this right
st. Loup is always exploring surprised
be intrigued be delighted the world
chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
is that you mr. PK your autograph of
course I think it's pretty cool that you
love chess so much we love chess to
enjoy school chess program and gotta
meet a real-life Grandmaster I had this
big one time I put a police captain
after school and check wait a min 27
moves wow I should be asking for your
autograph
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org you
may have heard about st. Louis's
world-class museums art history
even magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
whose kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
no matter your age or skill level chess
is a great game to learn and play the
same lose chess club offers affordable
memberships for families students and
individuals there's so much going on at
the club with lectures classes ladies
nights and tournaments in addition
there's always a Grand Master in
residence to help teach learn and play
come join us at the st. Louis chess club
and see what chess has to offer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our live coverage of the
2020 protest League match number one of
the st. Louis Archbishop's world
champions against New York marshals of
course three rounds have already been
played of this four round match we have
eight points so far clinching italia in
the match we just need a half point in
this final round and we do but hopefully
our players are gonna do once a 4-0 yeah
let's for oh this this final yeah once
again of course my name is Caleb Denby
I'm joined by the wonderful Archbishop
Doris Adair Shani and we are giving you
the live coverage today and without
further ado I think just about getting
started why don't we check it out of
course in this final round board one
plays board one board two plays board
two four three plays four three and four
four plays board for we have board one
Nakamura against board one Cara wanna
Kabir who sign up against Lenny a
dominguez Wesley so against Sam studyin
of course Lee Anne we are champion board
for against Miranda for the New York
Marshalls that's what the I want to say
easy win I think it's the word you know
I trust Lee Emily to get to get the job
done and I in fact I trust all of these
matches to be very heavily favored for
us including Bobby Cara wanna against
Cara Nakamura I think you know a lot of
people think Bobby doesn't quite have
the same chops than your happenin blitz
as he does in classical chess but I
think they're they're very much wrong I
think Bobby is world-class in any form
of chess and I expect him to take down
just because he's better in classic
doesn't mean he can't be good at those
things yeah look obviously better and
wrap it than they're better in classic
Brett that doesn't mean that they're
just not one of the best then of course
yeah Bobby a world-class player and
Nakamura hoping to get it done for the
Marshalls but I'm expecting a 4'o result
or at least we can we can hope for the
Archbishop's here
if this scheme was interesting Italian
at well well I want to say to him but
something yeah there's some kind of
difference here an early night a 5-4
coming as well I'm so sorry then this is
a oh yeah yeah this is that and I think
there's a bishop before idea here too
but 95 is the stronger move okay so the
Vienna is usually noted by an early f4
question white and we didn't we don't
actually see that in this game but son
perhaps let's do the way the blanket
played yes I think the next few moves
for blacks should be Chi Luke pushed his
palm so to avoid any kind of before if
just precaution and then she could try
and relocate the night to maybe t 7c
five or even he wanted to go fool um try
and putting it on d4 but I do feel like
this night could be relocated right um
so it's interesting that you're
mentioning all these Queen side plans of
course White's play is generally gonna
be in the form of a King side attack
here this is what he's kind of
telegraphing brings this night to g3
perhaps the signs coming to f5 the
Queen's already committed to the f3
square expect to see ideas of Bishop
takes h6 and that takes h6 and so by
bringing this night from f6 it seems
like you're removing a defender but
actually you're allowing the Queen to
come to f6 yeah yeah and well black
could also try and have ideas with
ideally f5 to completely call call the
attack off right f5 well sometimes a
weakening move in this case it brings
the rook into the action and allows the
the rip to be both an active attacker
and a nice defender but I think that's
something for probably to decide but I
hold on a sec are trying to do long
castle
aha this was Badou I wouldn't do be so
that so yeah it was right they did relic
and relocate the knife every not the
direction I was going but yeah and
actually that each Foursquare might be a
good good spot to put this Queen yeah
then maybe something like my chief oh
you have enough to working with the
night to to attack the key Foursquare as
well
a lot of a lot of good things happening
for Fabi here like his position yeah
he's comfortable in this position I
always favor the bishops as well and
that's another edge for Fabi screen does
come to h4 and now I think Nakamura also
understands the power of the bishops see
any tries to take off this starts do you
want the age to call it the bluff if you
think I take back yeah rook d8 but I'm a
little wary of this Bishop on b2 yellow
white to capture on c5 regardless yeah
on the other hand well you do have
Bishop b4 if if you want c3 yeah and the
CEO subsea tree the c3 would kind of
stunt the bishop right if c3 maybe
simply push it back to c5 or even a five
right now you've you've locked off this
bishop now I see you didn't you it's not
like it's not that you wanted to keep
your Bishop you wanted to make it more
uncomfortable for coupons they didn't
see so strengths rumored well not after
Bishop see through there's there's
actually Bishop a3 and it's a little
unclear the bishops are getting traded
yeah alright let's take a little time
off of this game and let's Bobby do some
moves so that's alright let's take a
look at Leslie so against the same 7
yeah and this looks like I'm gonna say
it up and no knee when I write this time
it looked like yeah you've been waiting
for your banana I've been waiting for it
but yes so we do have just a standard
Benoni here
weird stuff with the banana has black -
good while ago it was love me - what I'm
sorry I was that I plant some weird
stuff that so I prepared a game for me
it was like a normal round that's
another thing goes 2015 and I wanted to
do this weird be fine so like I could be
wrong but it was something like maybe
here is b5 takes Knight c3 and then he
sings I've seen something like this
before I know my opponents just it's
very logical very reasonable moves and I
was busted and yeah it didn't work out
yes it's like you're pretending you're
gonna play the Benko but then you said
you play e6 and Bishop b7 and you get
this pressure on the center but okay
instead we have a pretty standard Benoni
and white chose Knight f3 and Bishop f4
well I have to say I'm kind of impressed
with this Airport connection yeah of
course some insider info here Wesley so
believe it or not is playing from an
airport I'm not sure which one but the
airport Wi-Fi connection holding out for
the moment hopefully it continues to
stay that way maybe that's that's
something some some way that the New
York marshals could get back into this
mansion as if all our players disconnect
but hopefully no such travesties will
occur yeah very unlikely it's not like
there hey it's yes it's 2020 after all I
mean surely we can expect a good
connection I mean the opening could went
out pretty smoothly I feel like both
sides of good fighting chances honestly
and so
Sevilla isn't some it says he's an easy
player so you took down Fabio yeah
anybody's game so it's not unreasonable
to play a little bit more cautious or
just yeah it's it's interesting least of
all to say well right now this b7 pawn
is a little Wiggly yeah a little little
under pressure and you do not want to
commit to be six because then that makes
playing a a six and b5 much more
difficult and it gives a clear a 485
pounds
definitely relocated to d2 well that's
interesting I would not have expected
that but I guess there is this b5 coming
maybe yeah it was the the you know the
standard way okay I would be fine and I
would have expected to see that here as
well interesting though so 92 is his
choice perhaps he's aiming for an e6
square now this this looks like an idea
Knight f3 to g5 to e6 and that that
looks quite devastating if it works
where to where to pass are you gonna do
it with f4 or keep here on here to keep
defending Division I was thinking just
straight Knight f3 without without f4
what if h 6h 6 maybe then you're running
into Bishop e3 ideas and some
LightSquared weaknesses once you're
being good then this I'm not gonna I
don't really have doubts in this one how
is our Dominguez doing here we see Lenny
a and yet another Sicilian and
looks as though looks as though there's
some some very nice pressure on where's
the soil there white or black it's a
pond down that's a good point but okay I
mean you can play p5 yeah and you're
very nearly breaking through on to see -
yeah and this is this is not an easy
match either
definitely not how has might be a we
don't we might not have a clear answer
for this but um do you know the exact
results that's gather because I enough
did um I'm not totally sure I can
actually find that really quickly here
if you give me a moment sure and I did
want to say in this game I think f6
might be an interesting idea to try and
open up the bishop I feel like that's
gonna be very very relevant whether or
not this dark-squared bishop can uh get
into the game and yet you sign off
actually not having the best performance
for the marshals he scored just a half
point out of three he fell down to our
our combo Fabiano on board one and
Wesley on board two all managed to score
the win I can't say enough all right so
hopefully this well again we only need a
half a point and four boards to win this
match those little students I mean yeah
but every point counts you know there's
a lot to play for
so yeah Brooke g8 was actually his
choice interesting
I work g8 is being played on I don't
know if I'm such a fan of of what's
going on here of course the idea is to
take on f4 and then invade with
something like irk g2 but at the same
time
what if ya simply Knight 94 the end
yet the b5 is totally playable I'll just
take the time to play I think rook three
to d2 yeah I have to say unfortunately I
like to be worried I like white quite a
bit and as I say girl I think the key
point is this bishop on h8 I don't see
clear path back into the game and if
this bishop isn't playing well it's it's
tough to to prove anything
yeah I mean we'll see but let's take a
look at this game I don't think we've
seen Liam Lee yet against Miranda tricky
so far I like what I see at this point
at this moment but also you look at see
how they the open England's alright
alright good old cattle home everybody
loves the cattle in we see an early c5
firmer into actually not not so much the
mainline man and they're also really
taking on c4 okay so never white goes I
hadn't gets developed of course there's
no chief I depend on the age file he
won't be long looks just like a
comfortable lead and development here
for it for white but kami why can't they
just make castle
yeah so black is is I'm sure intending
to castle it the next available
opportunity but in the meantime is there
any way we can take advantage of this
late in development to maybe try and
grab one of these Queen side puns some
of like yet Cornett for hitting a seven
box looks tempting maybe you have to
play a six but a six isn't isn't my
favorite hoop in the world for black
hair factor some ephors men yeah oh wow
oh ow
I'm not ready not ready for all day I
just want to poke around on the Queen
side a little bit I don't see how you
defend this pawn actually crossing a six
yeah so maybe there's also a Bishop c5
but yeah this is gonna say I think a
problem with a6 is simply Queen b3 and
then you have the same type of problem
except at the beep on yeah running a
push b5 there as long as this a for you
excuse me
you're good so I think Queen a 7 here
must be the way it's proven in pirating
in the chance I don't think my question
is um somewhat a thing there's some of
the tension in these positions and I
agree these players are masters at
deciding one you know they need to
clarify things someone to keep things
complicated and more often than not they
they like to keep it complicated yeah
let's see what else he got so I think
Queen a7 and I'm not sure what he's
worried about specifically there is
Bishop c5 ideas but first I just win b7
is yeah a problem I will take that pot
so Queen e7 what is what is blacks idea
there if Queen b7 if Queen a7 Oh
interesting that he chooses not to take
what am I missing
hi I don't get it
I just don't get it maybe Bishop c5
Queen d7 is there can i play Knight g4
and just brute force this tree rook f3
absolutely
and then my work is also hanging on
deserts as well so it's yeah I preferred
to see Liam Leah take this pond on a
seven but perhaps he's thinking along
the mindset we need a half point I'm
gonna get the half point the other
players can try to win if they want I'm
clinching the mesh which is not a bad
way to approach a match play like this
agree okay good well quite a bit has
happened with Bobby against the car ooh
it looks like there's a huge imbalance
of - I'm holding yeah my good a stop
moving please nothing else been
therapies may be good so yeah we start
with H 494 we did see this Bishop go to
any tree we did see a 5/5 and yeah 95
was very much expected uh-huh Oh f4 okay
so f4 drives this night backwards I have
to say f4 was a good breakthrough yeah
for it looks looking very very nice ya
know f5 is coming through and it's Queen
on h4 well active is starting to feel a
little bit a little bit
this is trapped in front of the puns
kind of hurts yeah Bishop g3 ins this
Queen is already getting quite kick
around man just repeat yeah I mean yeah
unless there was something wrong
ah this is very funny about that
yeah Fabi decided to go for this oh this
wasn't nice tactic
95 yeah this is this is some high love
you got it take it mm-hmm you got a
ticket the Queen doesn't have anything
else to do and then there's there's 97
to save the peace and so Quinn takes
Queen fish 57 this night only seven is a
little bit stuck but there's no real way
to take advantage I must to take f6 yeah
good night
does escape three c6o wait why is H bar
I don't understand it saw this thing
some there one understands maybe there
was some 9500 I think that was the point
right but you just take back who Kings
you say so if you go back to h4 I
thought maybe white wanted to play
Knight takes e5 but it was worried about
Bishop f4 so h4 could drive the bishop
away but then he didn't follow through
with this idea which is confusing to me
I'll be sorting the side okay yeah but
can't do it yourself so just take this
there's a lot of media trip and then you
can slowly stop pushing you guys
well f5 could be a nice way to gain
counter play yeah what would happen in
the game though let's sleep ketchups
there they're playing a lot of this okay
so why it's points for the pawns why is
okay
and f5 does come this is this is a wild
endgame my hats out well I think I can
say anything else but the wool yeah this
is this is this is this beyond me
I had awful zero here so at first glance
it looks as though the white pawns on
the Queen side are going to be quite
dangerous they're a bit further advanced
than black center and so this move I
think is good news for Fabi if nothing
else you can play King takes G for
creating for yeah I'll just play Rick at
four and I don't think you can win this
game I think I'm gonna always have some
perpetual right there's no shelter for
for the White King right but perhaps you
can play King e6 II really need for rook
f8 a g6 is hanging well okay I'm out of
ideas
King out for I'll do it they're almost
people a king an f4 there is this Queen
nasty Quincy treating right so you kind
of have you only up I want to say two
realistic options Kings you fun if you
can call a [ __ ] Leslie and King takes
Jim g5 Queenie for where do you go hey
five pounds hanging ya know this this is
maybe this move is quite nice g4 was
awesome kudos let's take a quick look at
this game what is go so many many things
that happened Lots we fast okay why not
Queen I was just gonna say Queen a7 but
I guess Knight a5 what what what what's
hello okay okay you have to plane out of
five there you have since 95 it seems
you in advance
well oh yeah we didn't listen champions
what a way to end a like alright we what
thank you so much that was so strange
no not five was with obvious yeah well
hey what's still I think yeah I mean
there's problems Ricky one might might
be coming this mines retreat the dealer
Marley yeah I mean this games far from
over if not yeah it gets angry I don't
know how this was missed and like 95 is
such a strange move like there's if you
think you have 95 there's no way your
opponent would have allowed this right
like you don't play Queen I said that
might be five is possible you just you
don't do it you don't love this you
don't play winning some of them thinking
every five so Wesley so clinching the
match for us bringing us up to 89 points
I love this picture
yes mostly with a very nice cat yeah all
right
yeah so this game wow
I was gonna say it looked better than
the last time we looked but it looked
pretty bad the last time we looks this
is giving up the extreme show but oh if
you move the rope or goggles there you
go there's this check here take bye-bye
looks like checkmate
so rook G for forest and we've already
won the match the exchange is falling
maybe you can pretend you're the the
white pawns are pretty fractured you
have good chances I think to pick up
this e5 pawn but in the end you know
Rick's tricks are very simply this
should be a doable one for our opponents
yeah but okay let's let's think about it
right so let's say night before rook
before and then I don't know what white
wants to play but I'm gonna play keen e7
King e6 and I'm going to make a serious
attempt to to take this e5 pawn
a serious attempt but you know obviously
there's there's gonna be problems for
black as well maybe things like her case
three could come and then the H pond is
gonna be very difficult to stop it if
you manage to play rock age seven
never there's this a nice shake - oh
wait hold on see ya Musa 4666 ah so this
is White's idea rather than allow black
the option to join and take out the
spawn you're trading an offer for the
eighth time so Lydia of course obviously
it's very very long time and okay this
two rooks against York and Bishop is a
lot easier to try to hold than one
Bishop versus one rook oh this is a
slender so it's not so it's pretty good
keep liking f2 he could he could play
gonna do but but this one should should
be a win hey got a little waste time
here why don't we get back to this Lobby
game because this is doesn't ridiculous
where were we we we're somewhere yeah we
just saw g4 nothing did obsolete King 64
and he was for King h5 giving up on on
that epon as well and after g4 we see
Fabi making quite a bit of sanity check
you uh did you go back I think King h4
and maybe maybe Bobby is ready to accept
a perpetual alright but instead we see
Rick F greens I'm not so sure things are
moving in the right direction for a
cargo in fact I think things are moving
moving towards chances for Fabi in fact
I wouldn't be surprised to see that
wouldn't be surprised to see a car take
the potential here
well King G [ __ ] though mg 5 and there's
no checks Queen up to a strange position
[ __ ]
yeah I 5 you take upon may be simply
Rick eight to e4 c7 you make a point you
make a point
oh we have another result so gue sign up
did actually defeat Dominguez yeah in
this game as we expected it's important
to note though a car we've done to eight
seconds just like eight seconds on it
yeah quick look oh okay yeah this game
also under time pressure
Lee Anne Lee up three pawns and hold on
history
oh wait wait but no this is oh I mean
you can get the night I think you should
give the night right no okay they take
the draw you could play King g1 if you
really really wanted to try no but yeah
it's it's too much yeah I agree this is
a good curse this is good result well
we'll take the draw there and so let's
let's jump back to this last game going
on between Harbor knockin brats
Fabiana Carolina so my goodness take
picture and we see Fabi repeating a bit
I think King h4 is a very reasonable way
to win to try to win this game King h4
what happens what what does white play
Queen a6 check you it you have King g3
and you're going to run out of checks
since I'm threatening mate whoa
okay goes for this instead you can play
you can't figure it takes c6 deuce a
queen
d5 check yeah you can't play
look either rook to e2 I think
okay we're good and all severe severe
time pressure check there should be a
professional at least yeah Bobby's
risking a lot here with the rooks you do
have an urgency thighs and my dismissive
of checkmating but you always have to
look out for nasty like queen forks you
know there's there's always some Queen
check that that can throw rock sit wait
a second yeah so yes I believe rook
takes rook takes Queen oh my god oh my
god Bobby does it again oh yeah shock
their butts uh
alright so King up for bootcamp Street
yeah there's there's no way to the P me
Hester I mean you put this waking you
for King you for know just just Ricky -
and then right through and thank you D
for Brooke D - oops yeah this is just
like into school can you fly I guess
King f1 is forced actually and I think
this was the blender but hold on well
King up one I mean obviously it's not so
simple right there's ideas of maybe
playing g3 with G to check and then
Ricky one being mate if you simply try
to Queen so yeah let's say so check
check if King f1 hang up on what's up
sorry this is a sinking yeah see a king
f1 [ __ ] g3 well there's stuff is Queen
h3 yes it's all too much
obviously King up what is a better try
why can't just play rook c5 pick this
guy yeah this is this is possible as
well and so yeah a lot of different ways
the car could have tried to hold that
game but this one ending up going fabi's
way and with that the match is concluded
the st. Louis Archbishop's do it again
taking an early lead in our I think our
division by winning our first match we
have the final results the car Nakamura
Falls to Fabi Cara wanna in that super
complicated to Rex vs Queen endgame
you sign-off does score a win in the
smash against lineage Dominguez Wesley
so defeats Sam seven and Liam Leigh
draws Miranda on board for bringing us
to our final score of five and a half
for the New York Marshalls to ten and a
half for the st. Louis Archbishop's a
very convincing win and with that our
score in the division goes to ten and a
half and then we get a bonus
ten points for winning the match is
twenty and a half points after one round
of plans and it's pretty awesome I have
to say so be sure to tune in next Monday
when we will be squaring off against the
UK lions I believe at an earlier start
time it sounds like 12:30 p.m. will be
the start of that match but I think that
concludes our our coverage of today's
games any final thoughts Dorsett
I'm still a little both shocked and
impressed and I'm sure a bunch of other
stress levels going up and ahead yeah
that was really among the craziest
rockin games and games about ever really
seen yeah I feel like I feel a little
same but I have to go work on my
indicated but ya know this was this was
awesome leading the congratulations to
all the players and the team manager
obviously Mike yeah I'm very glad of the
games and the results this was pretty
cool yeah well thank you so much for for
joining me dorsa I was a pleasure doing
commentary with a real life archbishop
be sure to tune in for our upcoming
broadcasts of course we'll be back here
next week I think yeah with the same
coverage of the protests League we also
have the Karen's Cup coming up in
February yeah
with that in mind that'll be a ten
player round-robin with the top female
players in the world I don't think the
the rosters just yet announced er not
Ross the players are announced just yet
but that will be coming out soon so keep
your eyes peeled if you're running from
February 6 to the 17th on us chest
champs calm for more details cup is like
the female version of exactly right so
let's think feel Cup is for the top
overall players in the world this is for
the top female players in the world to
get a chance to shine here in st. Louis
so with that in mind thank you all so
much for joining us here today
we will be seeing you next month
and without a mind congratulations once
again to st. to the st. Louis
Archbishop's and Frankie yeah and we
will see you next time
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you